die heutige Entscheidung des Kabinetts
weil wir ja schon mal hier im Bundestag
sind wie das weitere parlamentarische
Verfahren im Einzelnen aussieht also da
hat man sich ja entschieden einen sehr
sicheres Verfahren mit eben entsprechend
fristwahrungen zu erhalten und dann hat
man gesagt 28 Oktober das soll dann der
erste Durchgang im Bundesrat sein das
ist ja sozusagen die das Recht der
Stellungnahme für die Länder am 9
November soll dann die erste Lesung hier
im Bundestag sein am 11 November dann
zweite und dritte Lesung im Bundestag
und dann gibt es entweder im Bundesrat
noch eine Sondersitzung am gleichen Tag
oder dann Ende November die
Verabschiedung aber für die Betreiber
war es ja tatsächlich wichtig ein
eindeutiges Signal zu bekommen und das
ist spätestens heute mit dem
beschlossenen Entwurf im Kabinett ja
geschehen so jetzt schauen wir aber was
uns an diesem Nachmittag erwartet der
zuständige Mister ist sitzt auf der
Regierungsbank also in vielen Kliniken
trifft derzeit ja die Zunahme von
corona-patienten auf ein dramatischen
Personalmangel Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach der plant nun Pflegekräfte zu
entlasten die Bundesregierung will
Krankenhäuser verpflichten eine
ausreichende Zahl von Pflegekräften zu
beschäftigen im Mittelpunkt steht ein
neues System zur Personalbemessung das
soll stufenweise eingeführt werden ab
2025 dann verbindlich gelten der
Bundestag berät also heute in erster
Lesung ein Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung zur
pflegepersonalbemessung im
krankenhaushaus sowie zur Anpassung eine
weitere Regelung da geht es auch um
Digitalisierung und
Verwaltungsvereinfachung so können wir
den Minister Karl Lauterbach
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute geht es
um das
pflegeentlastungsgesetz oft ist es ja
bei Gesetzen so dass man nicht weiß was
ich hinter dem Namen des Gesetzes
verbirgt hier könnten die Dinge nicht
einfacher sein es geht um die Entlastung
in der Pflege und weshalb brauchen wir
die Entlastung in der Pflege naja wir
haben die Situation dass in der Pflege
die Situation sich seit Jahren so
darstellt dass die Pflege belastet ist
und zunehmend belassen ist und das hat
sich durch die Pandemie eher verstärkt
und verschlechtert es geht nicht nur für
die krankenhauspflege sondern auch für
die Langzeitpflege wir sind aber heute
insbesondere mit der
krankenhauspflege beschäftigt und hier
haben wir die Belastung wir haben zum
einen sehr viele stationäre Betten im
internationalen Vergleich wir haben sehr
viele Eingriffe die eigentlich auch
ambulant erbracht werden könnten und wir
haben lange liege dauern außerdem ist
die Pflege in Deutschland so
strukturiert dass viele auf waren die
der Pflege eigentlich vorenthalten sein
könnten nicht von der Pflege erbracht
werden dürfen somit ist die Pflege in
vielerlei Hinsicht nicht so genutzt wie
sie genutzt werden könnte zu viele
stationäre Aufenthalte die Pflege wird
nicht voll in diese Bereiche gebracht wo
sie arbeiten wo sie helfen könnte und
dann eine Dauerbelastung was kann dieses
Gesetz also beitragen um der um diese
Problematik Herr zu werden wir müssen
die Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern und
dazu muss erst einmal
stationsgenau festgehalten werden wie
ist die Belastungssituation und das kann
man in denen eben dokumentiert wird
welche Pflege notwendig wäre und das
Vergleich mit der Pflege die vorhanden
ist daraus kann man die tatsächliche
Belastung dann ableiten und wenn man das
abgeleitet hat dann soll es dabei nicht
bleiben sondern dann folgt dann eine
Entlastung diese Entlastung kann zum
Beispiel darin bestehen dass wir FE
Frage mehr freie Tage also eingeführt
werden dass also Schichten abgebaut
werden dass es zu mehr Urlaub kommt dass
es zu Entlastungen kommt oder auch zu
einer besseren Vergütung und wenn das
nicht anders geht dann können auch
bestimmte Leistungen die nur erbracht
werden können weil die Pflege überlassen
ist die können da nicht mehr angeboten
werden da muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
das ist auch die ein oder andere
Operation nicht mehr durchzuführen wenn
eine überflüssige Operation durchgeführt
wird auf Kosten der Pflege aber da auf
Kosten einer dauerhaften Überlastung der
Pflege dann ist das nicht hinzunehmen
somit kann man das Gesetz auch wie folgt
beschreiben wir machen hier
ernst mit einer Entlastung der Pflege
wir dokumentieren die Überlastung wir
führen Sanktionen ein und diese
Sanktionen können dann auch so weit
gehen dass bestimmte Leistungen nicht
mehr erbracht werden können soweit sind
wir hier bereit zu gehen
das dafür genutzte Instrument PPA 2.0
ist das Ergebnis der konzertierten
Aktion wir haben das im
Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben dass wir das umsetzen
wollen das machen wir jetzt es wird aber
nicht die einzige Maßnahme sein mit der
wir die Pfleger entlassen werden wir
haben hier zunächst einmal die Situation
dass wir viele Eingriffe machen hier in
Deutschland stationär durchgeführt
werden mit einer Übernachtung wo die
Übernachtung medizinisch eigentlich gar
nicht indiziert ist und oft mehr
Probleme bringt als die Probleme löst da
wollen wir mit
Tagespauschalen dass auch Tages also das
quasi die also DRG die fahrpauschale
abgerechnet werden kann ohne dass man
übernachtet insbesondere die
Schichtdienste in der Pflege abbauen das
ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt wir haben
dann weniger Schichtdienste in der
Pflege das wäre eine wesentliche
Entlastung zum zweiten wir wollen genau
prüfen welche ein welche also Eingriffe
sind möglicherweise ganz eine stationäre
Versorgung möglich daher denen wir den
Katalog aus von Leistungen die auch
ambulant erbracht werden können die wir
derzeit stationär erbringen um den
stationären Bereich auf das
zurückzudrängen was medizinisch
notwendig ist und zum dritten wir wollen
darüber hinaus die Pflege auch so
gestalten dass Pflegekräfte auch die
Leistungen erbringen können für die sie
ausgebildet worden sind in Deutschland
ist die Ausbildung oft viel besser als
das was in der Pflege dann geleistet
werden kann weil viele Eingriffe viele
Verrichtungen der Pflege nicht erlaubt
sondern wo Sie diese sehr gut machen
können wir wollen daher den Beruf
professionalisieren auch stärker
akademisieren aber auch in der vollen
Blüte zur Tragen kommen lassen so dass
wir mit dieser Entlastung also mehrere
Achsen gleichzeitig verfolgen Entlastung
der Pflege durch die also durch den
Abbau von Schichten in der Nacht dann
eben das pflegeentlastungsinstrument wo
wir die Überlastung sichtbar machen wo
sozusagen zu einem kommen und bessere
Nutzung der Pflege indem wir die
Pflegekräfte auch an Leistungen
heranbringen für die Sie erstklassige
ausgebildet sind die sie bisher nicht
machen durften das macht wird den Beruf
attraktiver weil
ich komme zum Schluss also dieses
Gesamtpaket ist aus meiner Sicht aus
einem Guss es ist ein Paket wo wir auch
bereit sind Geld in die Hand zu nehmen
denn bessere Pflege ist teurer das muss
ja auch gesagt werden das ist teurer
aber es wird insbesondere eine bessere
Versorgung sein werden dann also lange
arbeiten wir mehrere Sätze
hintereinander bringen aber dieses
kurzfristige pflegeentlastungsgesetz das
ist wirklich etwas worauf die Pflege
sehr lange schon wartet was wir schnell
einführen werden womit wir die
Transparenz bekommen die wir benötigen
und um die Pflege zu entlasten und auch
jetzt ist nicht alles schlecht weil wir
diese Schritte gehen weil jeder war es
dass wir da ernst machen ist die Zahl
der Auszubildenden in der Pflege wieder
gestiegen auch die Zahl der
Vollzeitkräfte in der Pflege ist wieder
gestiegen und auch die Bezahlung steigt
somit ist es nicht alles schlecht wir
gehen nach vorne etwas langsamer als es
sein müsste aber man darf die Pflege
nicht kleiner reden als sie ist ohne die
Pflege werden wir also durch die wir
konnten durch die Pandemie gekommen in
deutsche Pflege steht stark und wir
werden Sie weiter starten vielen Dank
so und das der Gesetzentwurf von Karl
Lauterbach wird hier heute vorgelegt
also ein neues System zur
Personalbemessung stufenweise soll es
eingeführt werden letztendlich um
Pflegekräfte zu entlassen und natürlich
auch eine bessere Versorgung der Kranken
zu erreichen
Heinrich Dietrich monstadt jetzt für die
Union
stellen sich folgendes vor ihr Kind
braucht dringende medizinische Hilfe
doch der Krankenwagen fährt von einem
Krankenhaus zum nächsten weil die
Krankenhäuser keine Patienten mehr
aufnehmen und Ihr Kind deshalb nicht
schnell und angemessen behandelt werden
kann das ist keine Fiktion meine Damen
und Herren sondern eine Realität hier
bei uns hier in der Hauptstadt unser
Krankenhäuser sind so überfordert dass
sie kaum Patienten aufnehmen können
wachsende Defizite der Wegfall von
corona-ausgleichszahlungen statt
nierende stationäre Fallzahlen und
erlös-
auf erwartbare Blackouts Spitzen die
Lage dramatisch zu Herr Minister ernst
ist hier dringend geboten die Maßnahmen
dieser Regierung dieser Koalition kommen
zu spät es kommt schlichtweg zu wenig um
dem entgegenzutreten beziehungsweise um
unsere Einrichtungen zu entlasten
brauchen diese Häuser einen
rückwirkenden Inflationsausgleich meine
Damen und Herren von der Koalition wo
bleibt hier der doppelwumms unser
krankenhäuser müssen seit Jahren mit
immer größeren Problemen kämpfen
bestehende Investitionsstaus eine
Pandemie die das gesamte medizinische
Personal an die Grenzen gebracht hat und
ein Krieg im Herzen Europas der
steigende Energiekosten und Inflation
verursacht viele dieser Krankenhäuser
sind in schweren wirtschaftlichen
Schieflagen
Herr Bundesminister sie müssen dringend
handeln und nach meiner Wahrnehmung soll
die die Regierung sich weniger mit dem
legalisieren von kiffen beschäftigen sie
sollen endlich die wirklichen Probleme
angehen
dass ihr kommt alles noch Salz das hier
vorliegende Gesetz mit zum Beispiel der
Regelung zu PPR 2.0 ist nicht nur
handwerklich-mangelhaft sondern vor
allem inhaltlich es bietet faktisch
keine Entlastung für unsere
Krankenhäuser meine Kollegin Frau
Borchert wird hierzu näheres ausführen
im Gegenteil im Gesetz vorgesehene
Regelungen zu dokumentations- und
nachweisverpflichtungen für uns einem
noch höheren Bürokratieaufwand
Krankenhäuser ihre bereits begrenzen
Personalkapazitäten im Bereich der
präsentenversorgung dringend brauchen
müssen Pflegepersonal nun für diesen
erhöhten Bürokratieaufwand einsetzen bei
nichtbevölkerung drohen sogar Sanktionen
die die wirtschaftliche Situation weiter
verschärfen
unsere Krankenhäuser meine Damen und
Herren brauchen mehr Flexibilität
richtig wäre ein dynamisches System
welches eigenverantwortlich vor Ort
Entscheidungen ermöglicht wie und wo
knappe Ressourcen Personal wie das
knappe die Klappe ressourcenpersonal
eingesetzt werden kann eine sprechender
Initiativantrag unserer Fraktion hierzu
liegt vor die Pandemie der
Personalmangel die Energiekrise sowie
die Inflation setzen unsere Kliniken
massiv unter Druck die wirtschaftliche
Prognose für 2022 ist alarmierend knapp
70 Prozent der Krankenhäuser machen
Verluste in den nächsten fünf Jahren
wird sich die wirtschaftliche Lage der
Krankenhäuser weiter verschlechtern
Insolvenzen drohen in nicht gekannter
Größenordnung aber vielleicht meine
Damen und Herren hält es diese
Bundesregierung mit der
insolvenzdoptrien von Herrn Habig
Menschen werden dann ganz einfach nicht
versorgt und mit den dann ganz einfach
nicht zu verhindernden
meine Damen und Herren das ist
insbesondere für Menschen im ländlichen
Raum einen gravierendes Problem die
medizinische Versorgung im ländlichen
Raum droht ganz oder in großen Teilen
wegzubrechen diese Situation wird durch
den Fachkräftemangel weiter
verschlechtert ungeklärt um diesem
Gesetz nicht geregelt sind die Fragen
des Ausbaus der Telemedizin und
Telematik die hier zu einer Verbesserung
führen können das gilt auch für eine
weitere ambulantisierung wie auch die
angekündigte krankenhausstrukturreform
wollen Sie Herr Bundesminister dass
dieser Ausnahmezustand unserer
Krankenhäuser dauerhaft bleibt dass die
Krankenhäuser sich bei Notfällen
dauerhaft abmelden dieses Gesetz muss
dringend nachgebessert werden wir
stimmen dem Gesetz nicht zu herzlichen
Dank
Dietrich monstadt war das für die
Unionsfraktion er sitzt im
Gesundheitsausschuss noch ist allerdings
auch Zeit für die Beratung denn das ist
ja heute die erste Lesung dieses
Gesetzentwurfes des parlamentarische
Verfahrens startet ja erst Cordula
Schulz Asche jetzt für die Bündnis
Grünen Damen und Herren Herr Kollege
mondstadt ich
respektiere sie ja seit langem auch für
ihre Arbeit hier im Parlament aber ihre
Rede hier gerade hat mich doch sehr
erstaunt nicht nur dass sie hier
Vorwürfe erhoben haben nach einem Jahr
dieser Regierung wo zwei
Legislaturperioden acht Jahre lang
Gesundheitsminister der CDU hier regiert
haben und von daher wäre etwas
Selbstkritik angemessen gewesen und es
wäre sicher auch angemessen gewesen wenn
Sie zu dem Thema krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz und nicht über Hintern
Kunst geredet hätten danke schön die
professionell Pflegenden in diesem Land
warten seit Jahren auf spürbare
politische Entscheidungen die ihren
Alltag erleichtern die corona-pandemie
war eigentlich nur das Brennglas das auf
ein völlig ausgedörrtes
Gesundheitssystem entzündet hat und wir
können uns nicht länger damit begnügen
einzelne Feuer zu löschen sondern wir
brauchen endlich eine nachhaltige
Strategie für die Zukunft unseres
Gesundheitswesens
der demografische Wandel und die
demografische Wandel mit Alterung und
Fachkräftemangel ist eine der größten
Herausforderungen unseres Jahrhunderts
und trotz einiger Verbesserung auch
durch die Vorgängerregierung blieben
spürbare Reformen in der
krankenhauspflege aus und die
ampelregierung wird jetzt diese Reform
in Angriff nehmen die Arbeitsbedingungen
müssen besser werden damit Bürgerinnen
und Bürger die jetzt und in Zukunft in
ein Krankenhaus kommen noch gute Pflege
erwarten können dazu brauchen wir mehr
Pflegekräfte wir brauchen mehr
Pflegekräfte auch gerade bei den
Patienten und Patienten und das wollen
wir mit einer detaillierten
wissenschaftlichen
Personalbemessung erreichen diese ist
jetzt zu entwickeln für eine gute
Übergangslösung haben drei wesentliche
Akteure des deutschen Gesundheitswesens
nämlich der deutsche pflegerrat die
Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft und
Verdi gemeinsam die
pflegepersonalregelung ppr2.0
arbeitet und dieser Vorschlag wird jetzt
endlich auf dem Weg gebracht den
professionelle Pflege braucht jetzt
deutliche Zeichen für schnelle
Verbesserung und dazu gehört auch eine
verbindliche Zusage der entsprechenden
Finanzierung das sage ich ausdrücklich
dies und andere Unklarheiten im
Gesetzentwurf werden wir in den nächsten
Tagen ausräumen wenn wir in unserem Land
steigende Nachfrage nach
Gesundheitsleistungen bei gleichzeitigem
Fachkräftemangel in Einklang bringen
wollen brauchen wir auch eine
Strukturreform des Gesundheitswesens
dazu gehört die Zusammenarbeit der
Krankenhäuser mit dem ambulanten Sektor
wir brauchen Zusammenarbeit der
Gesundheitsberufe und insbesondere
brauchen wir eine Aufwertung der
Fachpflege dazu gehören
personalbemessungsinstrumente mehr
berufliche Perspektiven erweiterte
Tätigkeitsprofile und mehr
Selbstbestimmung der Pflegefachpersonen
und in diesem Sinne werden wir Pflege
Stärken nachhaltig aufwerten und zwar
konsequent in allen gesellschaftlichen
Bereichen nicht danke Ihnen
dr Christina Baum spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
um es gleich vorwegzunehmen mit diesem
Gesetz wird es keine einzige Pflegekraft
mehr im Gesundheitswesen geben denn die
Festlegung einer Personalbesetzung
ergibt überhaupt nur dann Sinn wenn
genügend Personal vorhanden steht ist
anscheinend hat Ihnen Herr Lauterbach
noch niemand gesagt dass es genau daran
mangelt und dies schon seit vielen
Jahren auch dass die geburtenstarken
Jahrgänge nun in Rente gehen und dann
über kurz und über kurz oder lang
zumindest teilweise auch auf Pflege
angewiesen sein werden dazu braucht es
keine Weissagung diese demokratischen
Zahlen liegen allen seit langem vor
warum fragen sie nicht die direkt
Betroffenen nämlich die Pfleger selbst
welche Voraussetzungen erforderlich sind
um wieder einen personellen Zuwachs zu
generieren ich habe das getan dazu
gehört primär die Anerkennung und
Wertschätzung ihrer Arbeit ordentliche
Arbeitsbedingungen mit mehr Zeit für die
Patienten vernünftige Bezahlung und
weniger sinnlose Bürokratie im
Mittelpunkt der Pflege muss immer das
Patienten wohlstehen die liebevolle
Umsorgung der Kranken die wesentlich zur
Gesundung beiträgt
was sie persönlich Herr lautebach unter
Wertschätzung verstehen hat die ganze
Republik erfahren als sie den
ungeimpften Pflegekräften nach zwei
Jahren Einsatz zurufen ihre Arbeit hat
keinen Beitrag geleistet und damit einen
Spaltkeil in die Pflege getrieben haben
denn es sind auch die ungeimpften die
aktuell viele Orts den Betrieb am Laufen
halten und dies aufgrund der klugen
Entscheidungen der meisten
Gesundheitsämter die sie bis heute
weiterarbeiten ließen diese Mitarbeiter
haben damit mehr Realität sind und
Verantwortungsbewusstsein bewiesen als
unser krankheitsminister was geschieht
eigentlich mit den Krankenhäusern die
die vorgegebene Personalbesetzung nicht
einhalten können weil einfach keine
Leute zur Verfügung stehen die werden
dann obendrein zu ihren
Personalproblemen auch noch dafür
bestraft dass sich durch politische
Fehlentscheidungen die Rahmenbedingungen
in den letzten Jahren so dramatisch
verschlechtert haben dass niemand mehr
in diesem Beruf überhaupt arbeiten
möchte oder sie müssen ganze Abteilungen
schließen oder werden gezwungen Betten
abzubauen um eine Strafzahlung zu
entgehen das kann jeden einzelnen von
ihnen auch treffen dass sie vor einem
verschlossenen Krankenhaus stehen
es muss deshalb für viele Mitarbeiter
wie ein hohen klingen dass sie diesen
Entwurf
krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz nennen auch die
jahrelange Praxis gut ausgebildetes
Personal aus ärmeren Ländern abzuziehen
war moralisch immer fragwürdig und von
vornherein zum Scheitern verurteilt weil
es keine dauerhafte Lösung sein kann
wir brauchen weder ein System das auf
dem alten Grundverständnis basiert das
Gesundheitsversorgung da seins Fürsorge
ist das nicht Wirtschaftlichkeit oder
gar Profit eines Krankenhauses sondern
das Wohl der Patienten im Vordergrund
steht lassen Sie die Pfleger wieder in
Ruhe und ohne Bevormundung ihre Arbeit
machen von der sie ohnehin nichts
verstehen
streichen sie endlich das Gesetz zur
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht dann
werden viele in ihren Beruf zurückkehren
und neue hinzukommen der pflegemangel
ist kein Mangel an personalgrenzen er
ist und bleibt ein Mangel an politischer
Kompetenz dankeschön
[Applaus]
Nicole Westig ist die nächste Rednerin
für die FDP-Fraktion
und sie ist für die Liberalen die
pflegepolitische Sprecherin
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen endlich liegt er vor uns der
Gesetzentwurf zur pflegepersonalregelung
2.0 in unseren Kliniken damit werden wir
die Arbeitsbedingungen in der Pflege
verbessern
Pflegerat Krankenhausgesellschaft und
Verdi haben die PPR 2.0 in der letzten
Wahlperiode gemeinsam erarbeitet aber
lange schlummerte das Konzept in einer
Schublade des BMG jetzt setzt die
fortschrittskoalition dieses Vorhaben um
dabei müssen wir ehrlich sein
die PPR 2.0 löst nicht mit einem
Federstrich die Personalprobleme in
unseren Kliniken doch als lernendes
System liefert sie uns den
entscheidenden Schlüssel dazu als
Bundesregierung senden wir das Signal an
die Pflegenden wir sind bereit
Transparenz zu schaffen und lassen zu
das Lücken sichtbar werden denn aufgrund
ihrer übermäßigen Belastung können
pflegende nicht vernünftig ihre Arbeit
nachgehen und weder den Patienten noch
ihren eigenen Ansprüchen gerecht werden
das schafft großen Frust und führt dem
schlimmsten Fall zum flexit und das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dürfen
wir nicht länger zulassen
die PPR 2.0 weist uns auch den Weg raus
aus den pflegepersonaluntergrenzen denn
diese haben ihren Zweck nicht erfüllt
sie stellen einen reinen rechenwerkwert
dar und sagen nichts über die
Pflegequalität aus wir brauchen aber
eine Personalausstattung die sich am
tatsächlichen patientenbedarf orientiert
der Gesetzentwurf schafft dafür eine
Grundlage wir müssen allerdings noch
einige Verbesserungen vornehmen so
gehört gerade die Personalbemessung in
der Intensivpflege dazu und muss konkret
benannt werden als FDP möchten wir die
Pflege Wissenschaft und das
Pflegemanagement aktiv in den Prozess
einbinden denn sie liefern uns Antworten
auf die entscheidende Frage nach dem
qualifikationsmix und der besten
Aufgabenteilung im Team
das Gesetz ist ein erster Schritt zur
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen in
der Pflege damit dies gelingt müssen
weitere Vorhaben wie Zahnräder
ineinander greifen zum Beispiel der
Ministerrats angesprochen die
krankenhausstrukturreform denn mit ihr
können wir das Personal das uns zur
Verfügung steht auch zielgenau einsetzen
gemeinsam mit den Ländern müssen wir die
Pflegeausbildung stärken mit
einheitlichen Qualitätsstandards für die
Pflegeassistenz und dem Ausbau
akademisierter Pflege besonders der
Pflegepädagogik ebenso gilt es die
Anerkennung von Fachkräften aus dem
Ausland jetzt dringend zu beschleunigen
Frau Kollegin möchten Sie eine
Zwischenfrage zulassen aus sind jetzt
fast am Ende
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen alles das
wird diese Koalition beherzt angehen ich
freue mich auf die weiteren Beratung ja
nicole wessig hat sich allerdings auch
für Verbesserungen noch ausge wir hoffen
hier und da an diesem Gesetzentwurf auch
der Bundesgesundheitsminister selbst hat
ja schon gesagt der Gesetzentwurf möchte
ja Nachschärfen an der ein oder anderen
Stelle die Kliniken sollen offenbar
künftig keine Möglichkeit mehr haben mit
eigenen Tarifverträgen die
personalvorgaben zu uns sehen zu umgehen
und die Kliniken die sollen
mittelfristig wenn Sie die
personalvorgaben nicht einhalten auch
sanktioniert werden
ist wirklich eine Frechheit eine
Frechheit gegenüber denjenigen die das
ganze erarbeitet haben eine Frechheit
vor allem gegenüber in Pflegekräften
hier im Land und dem gesamten
medizinischen Personal weil die mit der
Vorlage nun wirklich niemals entlastet
werden aber
um es beispielhaft es ist beispielhaft
für das Ministerium und ein Lauterbach
und zwei in drei Punkten erstens
Lauterbach und seinen Ministerium
scheint überhaupt nicht den Anspruch auf
eine Richtlinienkompetenz für den
Gesundheitsbereich zum sitzen oder zu
verlangen das hat man bei der
pandemiepolitik vermehrt feststellen
dürfen und nun steht im vorliegenden
Gesetz das
Bundesfinanzministerium sogar mit
Vetorecht und daher die Frage im Raum
steht woher das Geld in der jetzigen
angespannten Situation für die
Einstellung notwendiger Pflegekräfte
kommen soll ist der Entwurf mit dem
Vetorechten und wirklich ein schlechter
Witz und wir sorgen wir beschweren uns
immer wieder mal gemeinsam mit der CDU
dass der Gesundheitsminister so sehr
selten unseren ausschussbesuch Ausschuss
besucht und ich will einfach vorschlagen
wir können uns mal ehrlich machen laden
wir den Finanzminister ein der taugt mir
politisch zwar noch weniger aber er
scheint irgendwie Entscheidungskompetenz
in diese Regierung zu besitzen zweitens
der Koalitionsvertrag ist für Lauterbach
Herrn Lauterbach obsolet und das ist nun
wirklich bemerkenswert von der SPD nun
nicht nur von der SPD aber es Meister
gewohnt dass vor der Wahl Sachen
versprochen werden danach aber nicht
umgesetzt werden bei Herrn Lauterbach
sind selbst nach der Wahl
unterschriebene Koalitionsverträge
Makulatur das Versprechen in
Koalitionsvertrag war wir setzen
kurzfristig PPR 2.0 um nun schreiben die
Erfinderinnen und Erfinder der
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 das steht gar
nicht drin der Pflegerat DKG Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft und Verdi haben
das Konzept erarbeitet sie schreiben ich
zitiere dem jetzt vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf fehlt der eindeutige
Bezug zur pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 und
weiter der Entwurf birgt die Gefahr dass
das gesamte personalbemessungssystem
verpufft die Umsetzung des PPR 2.0
bleibt offen
drittens und das verdient nun wirklich
irgendwie Respekt der
ankündigungsminister Lauterbach der ein
Jahr lang von Ankündigungen allein lebt
der seit einem Jahr wird auf einen
winzigen Pflege Bonus kein
koalitionsversprechen umsetzte schafft
es nun selbst ein Gesetz zu schaffen das
nahezu ausschließlich ankündigt prüft in
Aussicht stellt aber keine Regelung
umsetzt sondern das eigentlich
entscheidende in Verordnungen regeln
will das ist nun wirklich richtig
spannend Herr Lauterbach wir werden im
Ausschuss einiges zu tun haben um das
alles noch irgendwie zu retten denn ich
passe zusammen das ist das Gesetz eines
Ministers der von Ankündigungen lebt
Versprechen nicht einhält und die
rechtskompetenz dann sogar noch in
anderen Minister abschiebt es könnte
witzig sein in der Pandemie ist es eine
Frechheit eine Frechheit für die
Pflegekräfte und das gesamte
medizinische Personal das seit Jahren
für ein Licht am Ende des Tunnels kämpft
dass den Laden am Laufen hält und nun
einen nicht regelnde Ankündigung erhält
die vom Finanzminister abhängig ist im
wahrsten Sinne also danke für nichts
Herr lauterbach danke für nichts
ja für Stirnrunzeln nicht nur bei der
Linken sondern auch bei Krankenkassen
ruft tatsächlich ist verantwortlich ein
Passes und Gesetzentwurf der
nachträglich noch eingearbeitet wurde da
heißt es Einzelheiten der
Personalbemessung würden durch
Rechtsverordnung im Einvernehmen mit dem
Bundesministerium der Finanzen
festgelegt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ein
seltenes Bild mal die CDU und die Linke
in Eintracht zu sehen hier im Plenum
also
kommen wir zur Sachebene seit dem
Frühjahr 2020 hat die corona-pandemie
den Alltag im ganzen Land auf den Kopf
gestellt die Krise hat wie ein Brennglas
bereits vorher bestehende Probleme oft
offengelegt und verstärkt
krankheitsbedingte Personalausfälle in
Krankenhäusern sind Mittel haben
mittlerweile flächendeckend zugenommen
und 90 Prozent davon in den Patienten an
Bereichen und am stärksten betroffen von
krankheitsbedingten Ausfällen sind die
Pflegekräfte viele Ausfälle also wegen
Corona die Personaldecke bei
Pflegekräften die ist dadurch noch
stärker ausgedünnt worden als sie es
jetzt schon ist und dementsprechend ist
der Fachkräftemangel offenkundig der
Mangel also an helfenden Händen und der
wurde spätestens mit der corona-pandemie
quasi demaskiert und verstärkt aber
Corona ist dabei leider nicht das
einzige Problem Pflegekräfte scheiden im
zunehmende Maße aus Gesundheitlichen
weitere vorzeitig aus ihrem Beruf aus
sie benennen dabei Belastungsfaktoren
Zeitdruck hoher Verwaltungsaufwand
organisatorische Mängel körperliche
Belastung und der demografische Faktor
wandelt spielt ebenfalls eine Rolle in
den nächsten 10 bis 12 Jahren gehen ca
500.000 Pflegefachkräfte in Rente der
Mangel wird sich also verstärken was
steigendem Bedarf um den Bedarf abdecken
zu wollen braucht es mehr helfende Hände
dafür müssen wir neue Kräfte sicherlich
rekrutieren und alte zurückholen die
Studie der Hans-Böckler-Stiftung ich
pflege wieder wenn zur Berufsrückkehr
und Arbeitszeit Aufstockung von
Pflegekräften zeigt auf Fliege viele
Pflege Pflegefachkräfte wären bereit in
ihrem Beruf zurückzukehren Uri ihre
Stunden zu erhöhen wenn Sie dort eine
deutliche Verbesserung der
Arbeitsbedingungen vorfinden würden es
gibt nicht dass eine Patentrezept das
ist uns allen klar den bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen erfordern mehr
Pflegepersonal und andersherum um mehr
Pflegepersonal gewinnen zu können
braucht es eine deutliche Verbesserung
der Arbeitsbedingungen
wir als Politik müssen dementsprechend
die Negativspirale aufbrechen denn bei
sehr vorsichtiger Kalkulation beläuft es
sich jetzt schon dass ca 300.000
Pflegekräfte in Vollzeit und in einem
optimistischen Szenario sogar auf
660.000 Vollzeitkräfte die zurückgeholt
werden könnten das heißt also wir
brauchen eine angemessene Bezahlung
durch weitere Aufwertung der
Tarifbindung aber Geld ist nicht alles
wir brauchen ein vereinfachte
Dokumentation Bürokratieabbau
Digitalisierung und essentiell dabei
ausreichende Zeit für eine gute Pflege
durch bedarfsgerechte Personalbemessung
verlässliche Arbeitszeiten durch
teambasierte Dienstplan Gestaltung sowie
ausfallmanagement im Koalitionsvertrag
meine Kollegin hat es vorhin auch gesagt
haben sich die forschungskoalition dazu
darauf verständigt sie möchte
entsprechend mit dem hier vorliegenden
Entwurf zum krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz den nächsten Schritt
gehen für das ich Ihnen Herr Minister
und ihrem Haus ausdrücklich danke denn
wir gehen jetzt einen Schritt weiter wir
wollen eine angemessene
personalerstattung in der Pflege
Krankenhaus und essentiell um
Arbeitssituation der Pflegekräfte als
auch die Qualität der
Patientenversorgung spürbar zu
verbessern ziel ist es dabei mit dem
hier vorliegenden Gesetz Transparenz
über die personaldefizite herzustellen
und darüber hinaus Krankenhäuser zu
verpflichten die Defizite mittel bis
langfristig auszugleichen die Maßnahme
um die personalstation in der Pflege im
Krankenhäusern zu verbessern führen wir
entsprechend die pflegepersonalregelung
2.0 PPR 2.1 in zwei in drei Phasen einer
probungsphase ab Anfang 2023 eine
Einführungsphase ab Januar 24 und dann
einer dritten Phase der Konvergenzphase
die Einführung wird mit Augenmaß
Erfolgen der Wunsch wird nicht sofort
Wirklichkeit werden das muss uns klar
sein aber wir schaffen die
Rahmenbedingungen um den Bedarf der
Pflege so attraktiv wie nur möglich zu
machen
die forschungskoalition löst mit der
Einführung einer solchen verbindlichen
Personalbemessung im Krankenhaus ihr
Versprechen ein sich mittels
struktureller Veränderungen für gute
Arbeit in der Pflege einzusetzen gute
Arbeit
gute Arbeit in der Pflege hat nicht nur
mit Respekt und Anerkennung für
Beschäftigte zu tun ja auch das aber
insbesondere auch mit menschlicher Würde
von Patientinnen und Patienten die auf
eine qualitativ hochwertige Pflege
angewiesen sind in diesem Sinne freue
ich mich auf die ausschussberatung und
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Simone Borchert hat jetzt das Wort für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
Gesundheitsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
Folge der Pandemie herrscht nicht nur in
der klinischen Pflege ein
Ausnahmezustand
Abfälle sind auf dem Höchststand viele
Beschäftigten halten diese extreme
Mehrfachbelastung nicht mehr aus und
wollen aus diesem Beruf heraus
verstärkend kommt noch die Idee von
unserem Gesundheitsminister hinzu dass
jetzt die Nachtdienste wegfallen sollen
das sage ich das kann doch nicht
wirklich ihr Ernst sein damit gefährden
wir die Versorgung der Patientinnen und
Patienten und vor allem die Qualität der
Versorgung sie machen hier den ganzen
Zinnober angeblich um die Qualität zu
verbessern und dann kommen sie mit so
einer Idee um die Ecke das kann nicht
wirkliche Ernst sein
sie kochen auf die Einhaltung starke
Quoten und Schlüssel und damit
verschärfen sie die ganze Situation noch
legen Sie doch einfach mal die
Verantwortung in die Hände derjenigen
die die meiste Fachkompetenz haben und
setzen sie sich mal mit Kliniken und
Krankenhäusern an eigenen Tisch sie
versuchen nämlich gerade als Politik die
besseren Manager zu sein das
funktioniert so nicht
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
wegen der schlechten Bezahlung gehen die
Beschäftigten aber schon lange nicht
mehr auf die Straße die Vergütung für
die Pflegenden hat sich in den letzten
Jahren massiv verbessert was jetzt
fortgeführt werden muss ist die
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen mit
ihrem Vorschlag machen sie aber genau
das Gegenteil mit ihrem Gesetzesentwurf
verfehlen sie das Ziel vehement und das
mit ganz klarer Ansage ich mache Ihnen
das gerne auch an einem Beispiel sehr
deutlich sie wollen mit der PPR 20 ein
Neues
personalbemessungsinstrument einführen
ab dem Jahr 2025 veranschlagen sie 5000
zusätzliche Pflegekräfte im
Klinikbereich die Bundesregierung selbst
geht von einem zusätzlichen Bedarf von
63.000 vollzeitpflegekräften allein in
Krankenhäusern bis zum Jahr 2030 aus
diese Info haben wir aus einer kleinen
Anfrage das ist unterm Strich eine
Mogelpackung aller erster Güte das wird
Situation in der Pflege nicht gerecht
und meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
momentan ist es auch so dass es für
jeden Pflegenden ein Bett eine
vollständige Refinanzierung gibt durch
die Krankenkassen ob der Bedarf
vorhanden ist oder nicht das verschärft
das Problem der abwehrung es wird aber
keine einzige Pflegekraft zusätzlich
dadurch geben am Markt und deswegen
meine Damen und Herren überdenken Sie
diese starren Quotenregelung lassen sie
mehr Dynamik und Eigenverantwortung zu
schaffen sie endlich Anreize für ein
effizienten Einsatz von Beschäftigten
und finanziellen Ressourcen damit sorgen
sie dann nicht nur für bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen sondern sie entlasten
auch die Beitragszahler vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Simone Borchert von der cdu/csu-fraktion
ja bezweifelt das mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
für Pflegekräfte zu erreichen sein und
sie hat auch noch mal die PPA 2.0
angesprochen nur noch einmal erklärt die
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 ist
Instrument zur pflegepersonalbemessung
uns heute in der ersten Lesung zu einem
sehr wichtigen Gesetz wie der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ist am Anfang
bereits eingeführt hat wir treten ein in
eine wichtige Phase
überfälliger Reformen im Bereich der
Pflege die seit vielen Jahren hätten auf
den Weg gebracht werden sollen wir haben
im Koalitionsvertrag eine Forderung von
Gewerkschaften von der Pflege selbst von
Fachgesellschaften von der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft aufgegriffen
endlich eine Personalbemessung im
Bereich der Pflege einzuführen die Licht
ins Dunkel von Defiziten im Bereich der
krankenhauskrankenpflege bringt die seit
Jahren bekannt aber nicht
quantifizierbar ist die Koalition hält
Wort setzt um was die Forderung aus der
Gesellschaft ist und das ist Gegenstand
des Gesetzes
wenn wir uns nun mit dem vorliegenden
Gesetzesvorschlag auseinandersetzen ist
aus dem Kreis der Union zu hören gewesen
dass wir eine Situation haben wo den
Kliniken wo den Menschen im
Gesundheitswesen das Wasser bis zum Hals
steht ja das ist richtig wir erleben
gerade eine neue Herbst winterwelle die
in erheblichem Maße die Menschen in den
Krankenhäusern belastet die durch
Krankheitsausfälle dazu führt dass die
Versorgung an verschiedenen Stellen wie
es Herr Mund statt richtig vorgetragen
hat wirklich ernst zu nehmen gefährdet
ist das heißt das allererstes was wir
tun müssen die infektionsdynamik
kurzfristig zu bekämpfen die Länder sind
aufgefordert den Handlungsrahmen den der
Bund ihnen gegeben hat mit den
Infektionsschutzgesetz durch
maskenregeln im Innenraum umzusetzen um
hier kurzfristig Druck rauszunehmen und
gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig ist es wichtig dass wir die
langfristigen Reformen auf den Weg
bringen indem wir durch eine
personalabemessung einerseits
feststellen wo welcher Bedarf konkret
vorliegt ein Vorschlag der nicht nur aus
dem Kreis der aktuellen Koalition kommt
sondern der im übrigen von ihnen aus der
Union mit entwickelt wurde sie aber nie
den Mut hatten in den acht Jahren wo sie
das Gesundheitsministerium verantwortet
haben Klarheit über das Defizit zu
schaffen was de facto in unserem
Gesundheitswesen besteht diese
Möglichkeit dich hier ehrlich zu machen
bedeutet auch dass wir sehen wie sich
über Jahre eine Welle der Demografie auf
unser Gesundheitswesen aufgebaut hat die
uns jetzt gravierend bedroht in zwar in
doppelten Sinne einerseits durch
Pflegepersonal durch
gesundheitsfachkräfte die Ausscheiden
aufgrund von ihrem Alter andererseits
weil der Anzahl pflegebedürftiger
Menschen jetzt noch mal rapide zunimmt
und uns alle hier in diesem Haus in den
nächsten Jahren noch vielfach
beschäftigen wird insofern ist es
richtig an dieser Stelle nun
einzuschreiten mit Maßnahmen und hier
möchte ich noch ein Missverständnis
aufräumen was gerade vorgetragen wurde
nicht indem man einfach sagt nachts
kommt keiner zur Arbeit sondern indem
wir uns in Zeiten knapper Ressourcen
fragen welche Fälle müssen denn wirklich
im Krankenhaus behandelt werden oder
welche können sinnvollerweise aus
medizinischen Gründen ambulant viel
besser versorgt werden und Maßnahmen in
diesem Sinne zum Gegenstand dieses
Gesetzes zu machen hier Behandlung in
den armboratlantenbereich zu verlagern
das werden wir im Rahmen des parlam
Verfahren intensiven gemeinsam
miteinander beraten gegebenenfalls
ergänzen ich lade also die
Oppositionsfraktion ein hier in ein
konstruktiven Dialog einzutreten nicht
über das Gesetz zu schimpfen sondern
echte Probleme zu lösen vielen Dank
sagt Janosch Damen der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen so jetzt
hören wir hier am Rednerpult Maximilian
Funke Kaiser für die FDP
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen damit das nicht
zu kurz kommt dieser Gesetzesentwurf der
ist auch ein notwendiger Aufschlag in
Richtung Verbesserung Entlastung und
Fortschritt des Gesundheitswesens durch
Digitalisierung und Technik liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Ziel das
muss sein die Verbesserung der Pflege
der Vorsorge und der Versorgung der
Patientinnen und Patienten und
gleichzeitig eine Entlastung der
pflegenden und Fortschritt ist da das
Stichwort wenn wir über digital hilf
sprechen
die Möglichkeiten der Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitswesen die werden nun in einem
ersten Schritt endlich in die Tat
umgesetzt und ich möchte betonen es ist
ein erster Schritt und es werden auch
weitere Schritte durch die
Digitalisierungsstrategie die gerade von
ihnen angestoßen worden sind Herr
Lauterbach im BMG folgen wir machen das
nicht der digitalisierungswert sondern
wir machen das zum Wohle der
Patientinnen und Patienten durch beste
medizinische Versorgung und Vorsorge
machen das zum wurde der Pflegekräfte
durch einen erheblichen Abbau der
dokumentationsaufwendungen und zum Wohle
der Leistungserbringer durch einen
lückenlosen Informationsaustausch liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und genau dafür enthält dieses Gesetz
einige Stellschrauben zum ersten gehen
wir zum ersten Mal einen Schritt der
verpflichtenden Interoperabilität ganz
im Sinne der digitalstrategie der
Bundesregierung das ist auch ein
Paradigmenwechsel der digitalpolitik
hier in Deutschland dadurch beflügeln
wir die Verbreitung von zentralen
Anwendungen der
telematik-infrastrukturen Stärken auch
die Rechte der Leistungserbringer
zweitens stärken wir die
Nutzerfreundlichkeit digitaler
Anwendungen und drittens verbessern wir
die Verfügbarkeit und Nutzbarkeit von
Daten ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Telematik Infrastruktur die es mit
ihren zahlreichen Anwendungen wieder
elektronischen Patientenakte des
erezeptes und dem digitalen
medikationsplans eine Papier
verschlingende Raupe Nimmersatt sein
aktuell aber das hat nach dieser
Legislaturperiode ein Ende und dieses
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz das
ist ein erster wichtiger Schritt in
dieser Evolution es ist quasi der Kokon
ein wichtiges Stadium der Reife und
bekanntlich gefolgt das schöne darauf
folgend in diesem Sinne herzlichen Dank
maximilian funke-kaiser hat hier für die
FDP als deren digitalpolitischer
Sprecher gesprochen und sie haben gehört
warum nämlich weitere Regelungen dieses
hier vorgelesen vorgelegten Gesetzes
betreffen eben die Weiterentwicklung der
Digitalisierung beispielsweise
Nutzerfreundlichkeit von digitalen
Anwendungen wie zum Beispiel die Nutzung
des elektronischen Rezeptes
Maßnahmen die schnell und spürbar die
Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern
kurzfristig führen wir zu verbindlichen
Personalbemessung im Krankenhaus die
pflegepersonalregelung PPR 2.0 als
übergangsinstrument mit dem Ziel eines
bedarfsgerechten qualifikationsmixes ein
was ich hier zitiere er klatschen allein
reicht nicht das hat ihnen die Pflege
immer wieder gesagt was ich
was ich hier zitiere ist rund ein Jahr
alt und steht im Koalitionsvertrag der
aktuellen Regierung unter kurzfristig
verstehe ich dass etwas in den ersten
100 Tagen aktiv ins Parlament
eingebracht wird und unter verbindlich
verstehe ich eben gerade nicht dass man
ein erprobtes System noch mals in eine
Erprobungsphase schickt wie sie es tun
und die Entscheidungshoheit aus dem
Parlament über eine Verordnung in die
Hände des Ministeriums und des Ministers
legt
dass dann de facto ohne Beteiligung des
Parlaments in eine ganz andere Richtung
entwickelt werden kann und verbindlich
gegenüber der Pflege ist mit Sicherheit
nicht um das haben die Kollegen
angesprochen dass das Ganze
unterfinanzierungsvorbehalt also
praktisch in die Hände von Christian
Lindner gelegt wird deshalb fordere ich
Sie
auf die Dramatik die sich selbst im
Koalitionsvertrag beschrieben haben
ernstzunehmen und es nicht dem
Ministerium zu überlassen was mit der
Pflege passiert und ja es braucht eine
Revolution in der Pflege und wenn sie es
ernst meine mit dem Menschen in der
Pflege reichen wir Ihnen als
Oppositionsfraktion auch die Hand wir
stehen bereit für eine gemeinsame
konzertierte parlamentarische und das
ist der Unterschied parlamentarische
Aktion Pflege mit einem Bündel an
Maßnahmen den wir nicht einem
Fachausschuss der Arbeits- und
sozialministerkonferenz der Länder
überlassen können denn dies sind um
Moment federführend in dem was
eigentlich getan werden müsste denn das
wird dem Anspruch eines nationalen
Parlaments bei weitem nicht gerecht und
dass sie fachlich dringend Hilfe nötig
und benötigen wurde vorhin auch schon
angesprochen das sieht man nämlich im
Gesetzentwurf sie veranschlagen mit der
neuen ppr2.0 bis 2025 denn dann wird
erst das ganze Instrument scharf
geschalten 5000 zusätz eine Pflegekräfte
im Klinikbereich und gleichzeitig
beantwortet diese Bundesregierung auf
unsere Anfrage hin das bis zum Jahr 2030
zusätzlich 63.000 zusätzliche
Vollzeitkräfte im Klinikbereich
gebraucht werden das passt nicht
zusammen und dann frage ich mich ja was
denn jetzt deshalb lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam gerne in einer übergreifenden
parlamentarischen konzertierten Aktionen
Verbindlichkeit Schnelligkeit und
Wirksamkeit für die Pflege auf den Weg
bringen die Pflegekräfte in unserem Land
haben diese Unterstützung verdient
ja sagt Emmi Zollner hier für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion zum Abschluss dieses
Tagesordnungspunktes die Debatte hat
gezeigt dass doch hier noch einiges an
Bedarf besteht was man im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch mal
besprechen könnte nicht nur von der
Opposition sondern auch aus den Reihen
der koalitionsfraktion hat man da doch
das ein oder andere gehört auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister selbst hat ja
angekündigt den Gesetzentwurf doch an
der einen oder anderen Stelle noch mal
nachzuschärfen das ganze geht jetzt in
die Ausschüsse deswegen kommen wir
gleich zum nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt
da wird es gehen um die Unterstützung
für Studierende und Fachschüler die
Bundesregierung die wurde ja ziemlich
hart kritisiert von verschiedenster
Seite weil im sogenannten zweiten
Entlastungspaket zunächst keine
energiepauschale für Rentner und
Studenten vorgesehen war dann wurde im
dritten Entlastungspaket eine
Einmalzahlung angekündigt für Rentner
sind das 300 Euro da wurde übrigens der
entsprechende Gesetzentwurf letzte Woche
auf dem parlamentar Weg gebracht und es
sollen schon diese Woche verabschiedet
werden hier im Bundestag was aus den 200
Euro energiepauschale für Studenten wird
wann das ganze ausgezahlt werden soll da
gibt es doch noch einige Fragen die
Union und die Linke die möchte das hier
zum Thema machen wir hören die erste
Rednerin von der Union Katrin Staffler
45 Tage sind vergangen seit die
Bundesregierung das dritte
Entlastungspaket verkündet hat
45 Tage sei Ziel Frau
Bundesbildungsministerin über die
offensichtlichen Probleme in der
Auszahlung des Zuschusses einfach
schweigen
45 Tage in denen die Bundesregierung
immer noch keine Lösung gefunden hat wie
die 200 Euro auf den Konten der Studis
ankommen sollen
stattdessen hören wir seit 45 Tagen
immer nur Ausreden man ist ja ein
Gespräch mit den Ländern man ist mit den
Gesprächen in den Hochschulen man muss
erst die entsprechenden gesetzlichen
Grundlagen schaffen und so weiter und so
fort ich bin schon gespannt auf die
Ausreden die wir heute hier in dieser
Debatte wieder hören wollen
wahrscheinlich sind die gleichen ich
würde allerdings sagen machen wir uns
doch an der Stelle einfach mal ehrlich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen hören Sie
auf zu vertuschen dass die
Bundesregierung überhaupt keinen Plan
hat wie sie die 200 Euro Zuschuss
auszahlen
und ehrlicherweise ist es daher auch
überhaupt nicht verwunderlich wenn man
keinen Plan in der Tasche hat wie es
funktionieren soll dann kann man
natürlich auch nicht sagen wann die 200
Euro ausgezahlt werden und trotzdem muss
ich sagen ich bin fast rückwärts über
den vom Stuhl gefallen als ich gehört
habe dass laut internen Zeitplanung in
der Bundesregierung mit einer Auszahlung
im kommenden Jahr erst zu rechnen ist im
kommenden Jahr das kann unmöglich ihr
Ernst sein
der Kollege Kai Gehring
hat in der letzten Wahlperiode an die
ehemalige Bundesbildungsministerin
gesagt ich zitiere sie wäre eine
trödelministerin als es um die
pandemiebedingten Überbrückungshilfen
gegangen ist und später hat er ihr dann
ein ich zitiere wieder
unverantwortliches Krisenmanagement
vorgeworfen der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Jens Brandenburg der in
der hat in der Debatte zur sozialen Lage
der Studierenden vor zwei Jahren gesagt
auch da zitiere ich wieder abwarten ist
in der Krise gerade keine Lösung ich
verrate Ihnen was
bei der Überbrückungshilfe in der
corona-pandemie sind zwischen
Ankündigung der Überbrückungshilfe und
den ersten Anträgen die gestellt werden
konnten 40 Tage verlangen für vergangen
40 keine 41 keine 42 keine 43 auch keine
44 schon gleich gar keine 45 es waren 40
seit letzten Freitag also seit dem 14
Oktober geht jeder einzelne Tag an dem
kein einziger Cent bei den Studenten bei
den Studentinnen bei den fachschülern
ankommt auf ihr politisches Konto Frau
Ministerin
so und jetzt fordern wir deswegen als
Union dass das Geld aller spätestens bis
zum 15 November bei denen die es jetzt
so dringend brauchen ankommen muss das
ist das Mindeste was wir tun können und
wenigstens ein klein ein kleines
bisschen zu zeigen dass wir die Nöte
auch dass die Bundesregierung die Nöte
ernst nimmt
und ersparen Sie es uns bitte heute
dass sie sich wieder für die vielen
tollen Maßnahmen abfallt die Sie für die
Studentinnen für die Studenten schon auf
dem Weg gebracht haben wenn man sich das
nämlich mal genauer anschaut dann wird
deutlich dass nichts daran Wumms hat um
mal im Sprachgebrauch der Regierung zu
bleiben Beispiele
Heizkostenzuschuss da haben wir nicht
mal alle Antragsberechtigten den ersten
bekommen was dazu geführt hat dass in
der vorletzten Ausschusssitzung sogar
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der SPD
und von den Grünen gefragt haben wie
lang so eine Auszahlung überhaupt dauern
kann FDP verweist auf die Zuständigkeit
der Länder spannend nach neuesten Infos
heute im Ausschuss schaut jetzt zum
Glück mit der Ausnahme von Thüringen ein
bisschen besser aus trotzdem das
Ergebnis ist immer noch unzureichend
zweites Beispiel bafögnovelle wie kann
man stolz sein auf eine bafög-novelle
die von der Inflation schon aufgefressen
gewesen ist als sie überhaupt in Kraft
getreten ist eigentlich ist es traurig
eigentlich ist es traurig wie einfach
Opposition bei ihnen geht
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
gibt überhaupt es ist gibt überhaupt
keinen Grund wirklich gar keinen
überhaupt keinen Grund diesem Antrag
heute nicht zuzustimmen und zwar ein
sofortabstimmung keine Überweisung an
den Ausschuss keine lange Beratungen
keine Verzögerungstaktik mehr sondern
ein eindeutiges Jahr hier und jetzt die
Studenten da draußen die schauen heute
auf uns sie schauen auf dieses Parlament
in der Hoffnung dass wir Ihnen ein
starkes Signal senden enttäuschen wir
diese nicht danke
sagt Katrin Staffler hier zum Auftakt
der Debatte und in ihrem Antrag der hier
in dieser Debatte zugrunde liegt hat die
Union formuliert dass Studenten und
Fachhochschüler Fachschüler eben schnell
unterstützt werden müssen diese 200 €
ausgezahlt werden müssen so ist es hier
ja auch formuliert worden jetzt hören
wir mal was die SPD dazu sagt Lina
sehr geehrte ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer
wir befinden uns in einer Zeit große
Herausforderungen Wladimir Putin nutzt
Energie als Waffe das Ergebnis sind hohe
Energiepreise die die Inflation nach
oben treiben damit steigt auch das
Armutsrisiko insbesondere für
einkommensschwache Haushalte darunter
natürlich auch viele junge Menschen in
Ausbildung und in diesen Zeiten zeigt
die fortschrittskoalition dass die
handlungsfähig ist wir treffen schnelle
Entscheidungen damit sichergestellt ist
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger weiter
heizen können dass die Unternehmen
weiter produzieren dass die
Arbeitsplätze sicher sind erst diese
Woche haben wir die Entscheidung zur
Atomkraft getroffen die Gasspeicher
wurden in den letzten Monaten auf über
95 Prozent gefüllt wir haben wirksame
entlastungspakete für Menschen mit
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen für
Studierende für Familien für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner auf den Weg
gebracht um die Helenen hohen
Lebenshaltungskosten ein Stück weit
auszugleichen mit diesen Maßnahmenbündel
machen wir klar wir lassen euch nicht im
Regen stehen wir unterstützen euch
niemand in Deutschland sollfrieren oder
seine Wohnung verlieren diese Koalition
reagiert mit Augenmaß und Verstand
kraftvoll navigiert Sie dieses Land
durch die Krise
und jetzt komme ich zu ihrem Antrag weil
die Union sich in ihrer oppositionshalle
dagegen weniger kraftvoll wiederfindet
da wird dann auf der einen Seite
kritisiert dass einzelne Gruppen zu
wenig bedacht und insgesamt die Pakete
zu wenig bieten würden und gleichzeitig
wird von sozialtourismus und von
scheinstudierenden gesprochen so als ob
der Sozialstaat massenweise von
Betrügerinnen Betrügern ausgenommen
werden würde liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
wir sprechen hier von Menschen die sich
in einer existenziellen Krise Leben
nicht von Betrügern
Opposition
Opposition ist wichtig in einer
Demokratie gerade in diesen Zeiten aber
dieses zündeln an den Grundpfeilern
unserer solidarischen Gesellschaft
dieses erzählen von falschen Fakten
gefährdet unseren gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt der heute wichtiger ist
denn je
und darin einreizig auch Ihr Antrag ein
und die Erzählung dass junge Menschen in
Ausbildung von der Ampelkoalition
übersehen werden
als sie das in ihrem Antrag Schreiben
kommt die energiepreispauschale nämlich
sehr wohl auch jungen Menschen in
Ausbildung zur gute und zwar den 75
Prozent die neben die Nebenjob haben des
wissen sie auch das haben wir hier
mehrfach bereits geklärt und dieselbe
Gruppe kann von
inflationsausgleichsprämie profitieren
die steuerfrei von den Arbeitgebern
ausgezahlt werden kann dazu kommt der
Heizkostenzuschuss für bafög-beziehungen
es ist eine gute Nachricht dass über 90
Prozent der Länder jetzt den
hausgehaltskostenzuschuss eins in die
Auszahlung des Heizkostenzuschuss eins
in die Wege geleitet haben und wir
werden ja morgen den Heizkostenzuschuss
zwei noch beschließen der dann ebenfalls
schnell an junge Menschen ausgezahlt
wird auch dazu zählen natürlich die
deutliche Erhöhung des BAföG die
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns sind einmal
Bonus von 100 Euro die für Menschen in
Ausbildung bis zum 26 lebensjahr auch
des neuen euro-tickets
selbstverständlich profitieren junge
Menschen in Ausbildung auch von den
Vorschlägen der gaspreis-kommission und
den Vorhaben der Koalition zur Deckelung
der Energiepreise und jetzt nehmen sie
in ihrem Antrag ja Bezug auf den
Beschluss der Bundesregierung
Studierende sowie Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler eine Einmalzahlung in Höhe
von 200 Euro auszuzahlen und ich will
sagen das ist sehr begrüßenswert dass
sie diesen Vorschlag ebenfalls
unterstützen wir sind auch
mir einig dass die Einmalzahlung
möglichst schnell und unbürokratisch
ausgezahlt werden muss aber und es
wissen sie auch das ist herausfordernd
weil wir haben nun mal keine Datenbank
wo alle Namen alle Schülerinnen und
Schüler aller Studierenden drin sind wo
die Kontodaten drin sind und wir dann
nur noch irgendwo auf den Knopf drücken
müssen und das ganze Geld ist ausbezahlt
das ist nicht so und es wissen sie auch
und hilfreich wäre es von ihrer Seite
doch gewesen wenn sie mal konkrete
Lösungsvorschläge machen gemeinsam mit
den Ländern und der Bundesregierung
einer schnellen Auszahlung zu arbeiten
nicht hilfreich ist dagegen irgendwelche
vermeintlich einzuhaltende
auszahlungsdeadlines in den Antrag zu
klatschen das ist das Gegenteil von
seriöser Oppositionspartei dabei das ist
reine Stimmungsmache
ich möchte gerne auch noch was zu dem
Antrag der Linksfraktion sagen den wir
ja hier auch noch beraten der hat
nämlich deutlich mehr Substanz und
greift einige Initiativen unserer
Koalition auf wie zum Beispiel das
bundländerprogramm junges Wohnen dass
wir von der bundesbauministerin
angekündigt zum ersten ersten 2023
starten wird und auch in der
Strukturreform des BAföG arbeiten wir
mit Hochdruck
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen sie sehen die
Ampelkoalition lässt junge Menschen in
Ausbildung in dieser herausfordernden
Situation eben nicht im Regen stehen wie
sie es in ihrem Antrag schreiben
stattdessen spannen wir einen breiten
Regenschirm für Sie auf vielen Dank
nina seitzel war das für die SPD ja die
Heizkostenzuschüsse hat sie angesprochen
die 200 Euro die an die Studenten noch
ausgezahlt werden sollen auch gerade an
die die zum Beispiel auch kein Bafög
bekommen da ist die Sache tatsächlich
gar nicht so einfach den anders als
beispielsweise Rentnerinnen und Rentner
erhalten Studierende wenn sie keine
Zuwendung vom Staat bekommen hat man ja
keine Bankverbindung die zentrale
erfasst wird und die sind in Hochschulen
in der Regel ja dann auch nicht bekannt
also da müssen Lösungswege hier auch
zusammen mit den Ländern
Zeit über 200 Euro
200 Euro Einmalzahlung für Studenten
wir müssen nur gar nicht so weit
zurückgehen da haben wir hier über ganz
andere Pakete diskutiert 100 Milliarden
für die Rüstungsindustrie 200 Milliarden
letztlich für Energiekonzerne und hier
geht es heute um 200 und Euro da darf
man doch schon mal fragen was kann man
sich von 200 Euro denn eigentlich
leisten was kostet denn die Fahrt zum
Beispiel nach Hause zu den Eltern wenn
man das Ticket voll bezahlen muss im ICE
was kostet denn inzwischen eine
Tankfüllung ich hoffe von Ihnen wissen
das noch die meisten es gibt ja einige
Minister oder Kanzler sogar die nicht
mehr wissen was der Sprit an der
Tankstelle so derzeit kostet
ja und ich merke schon an ihrer Unruhe
dass das genau der wunde Punkt ist
nämlich das können sich viele Studenten
heutzutage gar nicht mehr leisten meine
Damen und Herren
und wenn ich mir dann angucke
Entschuldigung Frau Kollegin Salze sind
zwar gerade mit ihrem Handy beschäftigt
aber es geht ja auch hier um ihre
Politik und Sie müssen doch schon
zugeben sie haben das gerade so
dargestellt als hätte das alles sinn und
verstand was sie gemacht haben aber wenn
wir uns die vielen einzelgesetze
anschauen dann erkennt man doch in der
Gesamtschau nicht irgendwie ein
sinnvolles planvolles Vorgehen sondern
das einzige was ich hier erkenne was
meine Fraktion hier erkennt ist eine
heillose Flickschusterei der eine Fehler
den sie gemacht haben war ja dass Sie
dass Sie hier ein Teil der Studenten
vergessen haben ja sie haben an die
gedacht die das BAföG haben aber haben
dann gesehen wo es gibt ja noch andere
die beziehen kein Bafög so dann gibt es
jetzt die Einmalzahlung für andere auch
wieder mit der Gießkanne
sie kriegen das natürlich in der Kürze
der Zeit nicht hin zu differenzieren das
heißt diese 200 Euro wer bekommt die
denn bekommen dass die wirklich
Bedürftigen vielleicht auch aber es
bekommen auch die die es gar nicht
brauchen also auch hier ist kein System
und kein Verstand dabei vielleicht auch
noch ein Wort zu den beiden vorliegenden
Anträgen liebe Frau Staffler leider muss
ich sagen ist ja schon richtig dass es
alles schneller geschehen müsste und
ihre Kritik ist ja auch geht ja in die
richtige Richtung andererseits drücken
aber auch sie sicher darum herum die
eigentlichen Probleme anzusprechen denn
warum haben denn viele Studenten und
übrigens nicht nur die Studenten sondern
viele Auszubildende überhaupt alle
Menschen derzeit ein Problem diese
Probleme sind ja nicht vom Himmel
gefallen sondern die Probleme haben auch
zu tun mit der Sanktionspolitik die sich
und das wird immer offenbarer meine
Damen und Herren inzwischen gegen unsere
eigenen Bürger richtet
[Applaus]
deshalb wäre das der erste Vorschlag der
sich nicht auf Symptom Behandlung
bezieht sondern an die Ursachen
herangeht hören sie auf mit der
Sanktionspolitik sorgen Sie dafür dass
wieder ausreichende Energie auf der
Angebotsseite zur Verfügung steht dann
kriegen wir auch die Inflation in den
Griff und nur dann wenn wir die
Inflation in den Griff kriegen können
wir dieses Problem wirklich dauerhaft
lösen denn was wollen Sie denn machen
diese eine Einmalzahlung wird doch nicht
reichen kommt dann die nächste
Einmalzahlung vielleicht von 250 Euro
dann wieder 235 Euro wie weit soll das
denn noch gehen wir vermissen hier
Vorschläge die wirklich das Problem an
der Wurzel packen und dazu gehören auch
noch ganz andere Bereiche die ja zum
Glück jetzt sichtbar werden nämlich dass
ihre Energiewende die nicht sie allein
sondern auch die
Vorgängerregierung hier vorangetrieben
hat dass auch diese Energiewende ja mit
daran schuld ist dass die Probleme in
denen wir jetzt gemeinsam stecken
überhaupt so groß sind wie sie sind
deshalb unser zweiter Tipp für Sie um
wirklich an die Ursachen heranzugehen
nehmen Sie Abstand von ihrer verkorgten
Energiewende kommen Sie zurück zu einem
vernünftigen Energiemix dann geht es
auch mit unserer Wirtschaft wieder voran
denn nur mit einer funktionierenden
Wirtschaft kann letztlich auch Geld
generiert werden eingenommen werden dass
sie schließlich brauchen um es dann zu
verteilen vielen Dank meine Damen und
Herren
war das für die afd-fraktion am
Rednerpult jetzt für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 Grünen die Abgeordnete Laura
Kraft
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Zuschauer
auf den Tribünen so jetzt kommen wir mal
zum Antrag der Union also der lässt
ehrlich gesagt einfach nur zu wünschen
übrig denn das fängt schon damit an dass
sie behaupten dass nur vier Prozent
aller Studierenden in Deutschland von
dem Heizkostenzuschuss profitiert hätten
und dann verweisen Sie auch auf eine
bundestags-rucksache so damit da ist ja
schon mal der erste Fehler denn sie
haben ja in der Fragestunde am 28
September danach gefragt an wie viele
Studierende ist der Heizkostenzuschuss
schon ausgezahlt worden und da hat Ihnen
der Parlamentarische Staatssekretär
Mario Brandenburg erklärt und das war
dann der Stand vom 23 September das von
300.000 ungefähr 300.000
Anspruchsberechtigten schon 122.2
71 der ist ausbezahlt bekommen haben so
es sind nämlich nur die Bafög-Empfänger
in anspruchsberechtigt gewesen und nicht
alle Studierenden also ihre rumrechnerei
die ist da völlig Fakten befreit ist
gegen den ich nicht ja also da sind wir
nicht bei 4 Prozent da muss man einfach
mal wissen wovon man redet also das ist
ja nur ein Punkt in ihrem Antrag sie
behaupten sie behaupten ja da einfach
dass die Ampelkoalition die Studierenden
völlig vergessen hätte also das ist nein
das ist nachweislich falsch ich kann die
mal auflisten was wir alles bereits
gemacht haben oder im Inbegriff sind zu
tun das ist so viel dass ich das
Aufschreiben musste so Erhöhung der
bafög-sätze und Ausweitung der
bafög-berechtigung nothilfe-mechanismus
Kindergelderhöhung zwei zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse den einen denen sie
da eben schon falsch berechnet haben
plus der der jetzt dann morgen kommt die
Anhebung der minijobsverdienstgrenze
energiepauschale verwerbstätige
wohngeldreform 9 Euro Ticket wovon ja
auch Studierende profitiert haben und
dann auch noch mal die Einmalzahlung so
das ist aber nur ein Auszug des Ganzen
und Sie haben ja heute dann letzten
Endes dann auch im Ausschuss erfahren
was ist der Stand der Auszahlung hat
ihnen dann auch der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Jens Brandenburg erklärt
das schon 15 von 16 Ländern im
auszahlungsprozess sind bzw den auch
teilweise schon abgeschlossen haben also
da sind sie jetzt eigentlich auch völlig
auf dem Holzweg und ihr gesamter Antrag
da muss man ja ehrlich sagen so da haben
sie vier Forderungen von diesen vier
Forderungen also da wollen sie einmal
dass es unbürokratisch bis
allerspätestens 15 November ausgezahlt
wird dann wollen sie einen
unbürokratisches antrags- und
Bewilligungsverfahren digital
niedrigschwellige Nachweispflicht aber
auch Kontrollen so nee aber sie merken
dass das Zielkonflikte Sinn und das
Ganze bis zum 15 November sie wissen ja
dass die Bundesregierung auch mit den
Ländern im Gespräch ist und natürlich
auch versucht das ist nämlich nicht
banal das irgendwie auf dem Weg zu
bringen sie sehen da haben sie schon
mehrere Aspekte
nehmen Sie sich doch einfach mal ein
Beispiel an der in Antrag der Linken der
macht nämlich wirklich konstruktive
Vorschläge sie schlagen ja überhaupt
nichts vor Kollegen ja also ich glaube
nur das lohnt der Linken muss leider sie
können keine besseren Anträge stellen
aber ich weiß dass das stimmt
und das ist einfach unverschämt
ja Laura Kraft von den Grünen lobt hier
schon mal den Antrag der Linken dazu
haben wir noch nicht allzu viel gehört
dass wird jetzt aber nachgeholt ganz
sicher von Nicole nämlich die jetzt für
die Linke spricht
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja hier kommt
sie die konstruktiv Opposition ne es
waren also die Inflation und die krasse
Teuerungswelle machen auch vor den
Studierenden und vor den Schülerinnen
und Schülern nicht halt auch sie haben
Angst vor der Zukunft haben Angst um die
eigene Existenz und haben natürlich auch
Sorge wie sie unter diesen Bedingungen
eigentlich ihr Studium oder die
Ausbildung schaffen sollen jetzt hat
sich die Bundesregierung richtigerweise
dazu durchgerungen auch die Studierenden
bei den Entlastungen mitzudenken bislang
war es ja so dass von den Zahlungen
immer nur ein Teil der Studis profitiert
hat den ersten und zweiten
Heizkostenzuschuss konnten nur die
bekommen die Bafög beziehen also nur 11
Prozent der Studis und Studierenden die
energiepauschale wiederum haben nur die
Erwerbstätigen Studierenden bekommen
können und jetzt sollen eben alle
Studierenden und die Fachschülerinnen
und Fachschüler eine Einmalzahlung in
Höhe von 200 Euro erhalten das ist jetzt
zwar noch nicht so dass die damit über
den Winter kommen und die steigenden
Lebensmittel Energiepreise wirklich
decken können aber es ist ein Schritt in
die richtige Richtung wenn es nicht
einen Haken gäbe bislang ist nämlich
wirklich völlig unklar wie und wann das
Geld bei Ihnen ankommt und Frau Kraft da
muss ich auch sagen heute im Ausschuss
hat natürlich der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär über den Stand der
Auszahlungen beim Heizkostenzuschuss 1
gesprochen und nicht über die 200 Euro
und ich muss mich schon auch anschließen
und sagen Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Ampel stellen sie endlich sicher
dass die Hilfen ankommen das Geld wird
dringend gebraucht
und und es ist höchste Zeit auch noch
ein paar andere Ideen für Hilfsmaßnahmen
für Menschen in Ausbildung auf den Weg
zu bringen zum Beispiel der ÖPNV müsste
für Schülerinnen und Schüler für
Auszubildenden und Studierende endlich
kostenfrei sein das wäre doch meine
zielgerichtete Unterstützung und es muss
sich endlich was tun beim studentischen
Wohnraum die Wohnheimplätze der
Studentenwerke reichen hinten und vorne
nicht aus starten Sie jetzt endlich
durch mit ihrem angekündigten Programm
für junges Wohnen und für Auszubildende
auch das kann ich warten die Menschen
haben jetzt die Nöte warum dauert das
eigentlich immer alles so lange und es
ist Höch
die strukturellen Probleme anzugehen die
den Studierenden das Leben schwer machen
nämlich die Tatsache dass jede und jeder
dritte Studierende und zwar schon vor
Inflation und Energiekrise dass jede und
jeder dritte Studierende von Armut
betroffen ist und das eben nur 11
Prozent der studis-bafög beziehen das
ist doch auch das Problem was die
jetzige Situation so verschärft und was
eben auch
dazu ankommen nur ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein sind weil sie eben die
strukturelle Armut in der ein Teil der
Studierenden lebt nicht auffangen können
und deswegen nochmal es muss jetzt um
eine bafög-reform gehen die ein Studium
die eine Existenz tatsächlich absichert
ein Bafög von dem man die Miete und den
Internetanschluss sicher bestreiten kann
und dass ich automatisch an die
Inflation anpasst und diese Entwicklung
nicht immer hinterher hängt und ein
Bafög
und ein Bafög dass die Tür für mehr
BezieherInnen und beziehe nicht nur den
kleinen Spalt aufmacht sondern die Tore
weit aufmacht und dann Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel dann könnte man
auch mal wirklich von einem Wumms reden
um in der Rhetorik der Ampel zu bleiben
denn bisher ist das was sie machen finde
ich nicht so sehr Wumms sondern ein
bisschen mehr Puff ich bitte Sie um
Zustimmung zu unserem Antrag vielen Dank
ja und den hat Nicole Gohlke hier noch
mal mit ein mit einigen Einzelheiten
vorgestellt jetzt hören wir für die
FDP-Fraktion Reha Schröder sie ist die
bildungspolitische Sprecherin der
Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bildungsministerin hat sich erfolgreich
für die Unterstützung von Studierenden
sowie Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler
eingesetzt 200 Euro bekommt jede und
jeder Einzelne angesichts der hohen
Energiekosten ist das eine richtige und
notwendige Entlastung für junge Menschen
das BMWF hat letzte Woche im Ausschuss
bereits berichtet dass das Haus in enger
Abstimmung mit den Ländern schnell eine
Rechtsgrundlage und einen
unbürokratisches Verfahren zur
Auszahlung schafft und das ist gar nicht
trivial ich habe mich deswegen wirklich
gefreut auf die Anträge der Opposition
sie als Union haben da ja auch viel
Erfahrung im Haus und war wirklich ganz
gespannt auf Ihre Vorschläge für die
Auszahlungsmodalitäten leider wurde ich
enttäuscht und dann lese ich im Antrag
der Union auch noch von
Nachweispflichten um scheinstudierende
auszusortieren was ist das eigentlich
scheinstudierende damit zeigen Sie
leider einmal mehr ihren Argwohn und ihr
Misstrauen gegenüber jungen Menschen in
diesem Land auch deshalb werden wir
Ihren Antrag ablehnen
meine Damen und Herren die
Bundesregierung die lässt junge Menschen
eben gerade nicht im Regen stehen wir
entlasten Sie ganz konkret und ich
verstehe auch dass es manchmal schwierig
ist den Überblick zu behalten und wenn
euch das auch so geht dann aufgepasst
denn für Euch kommt jetzt eine
Zusammenfassung in zehn Punkten erstens
wenn ihr im letzten winter-bafög
bekommen habt oder aufstiegs-bafög dann
bekommt ihr den Heizkostenzuschuss 1 230
Euro in Hamburg wurde der etwa Ende
September ausbezahlt ganz unbürokratisch
und für diesen Winter entlasten wir euch
sogar nochmal mit einem
Heizkostenzuschuss 2 in Höhe von 345
Euro checkt mal ob der Zuschuss schon
angekommen ist bei vielen ist das der
Fall zweitens dank der bafög-novelle zu
diesem Wintersemester erhalten mehr
Menschen mehr Bafög auch wenn ihr das im
ersten Semester nicht bekommen habt
vielleicht auch nicht mehr im ersten
Semester seid dann ist das jetzt eine
gute Gelegenheit den Anspruch noch mal
zu prüfen beim online-bafög-rechner da
kann man das ganz bürokratisch tun und
bekommt eine erste Einschätzung das
BAföG ist eine gute Sache nutzt das
dritter Punkt
drittens wir haben zum ersten Oktober
die minijob-trends erhöht auf 520 Euro
und den Mini und den Mindestlohn auf 12
Euro wenn ihr neben dem Studium also
jobbt dann könnt ihr jetzt mehr dazu
verdienen mein Tipp ist übrigens auch
rechnet euren Stundenlohn mal aus schaut
sprecht mit eurem Arbeitgeber ob ihr
wirklich auch die die entsprechende
Erhöhung bekommt damit die 520 Euro auch
wirklich ankommen vierter Punkt im
Gegensatz zur Behauptung der Union habt
ihr mit eurem Nebenjob ebenfalls im
September die energiepreispauschale in
Höhe von 300 Euro bekommen ganz
automatisch über die Lohnabrechnung
fünfter Punkt das 9 euro-ticket das
haben viele junge Menschen gefeiert
zurecht mit dem digitalen
unbürokratischen bissing-ticket wird
Mobilität dauerhaft und einfach günstig
sechster Punkt das Kindergeld das
Kindergeld wird erhöht und eure Eltern
erhalten zum ersten Januar 2318 Euro
mehr im Monat also insgesamt 237 Euro
außerdem augen auf bei der Strom- und
Gasrechnung denn die siebte Maßnahme die
kommt im Frühjahr im nächsten Jahr mit
der gaspreisbremse und die
dezemberrechnung für eure WG oder eure
Wohnung die geht auf Christian Lindners
Nacken eigentlich auf dieses
Bundeshaushalt aber ihr wisst was
gemeint ist 8 Punkt durch den Wegfall
der EEG-Umlage spart ihr schon seit dem
ersten siebten 3,72 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde um sich das mal ein
bisschen vorzustellen für eine vierer-wg
sind das ungefähr 300 Euro im Jahr das
ist glaube ich eine ganz gute Sache und
der Stromanbieter der kann das auch
nicht einbehalten sondern der muss diese
Einsparung weitergeben letzter letzte
zwei Punkte 9 und 10 die
umsatzsteuersenkung auf 7% für Gas die
verschobene co2-preiserhöhung all diese
Entlastung meine Damen und Herren die
kommen automatisch bei den jungen
Menschen an und das macht Energie in
dieser angespannten Lage günstiger
so ich glaube das zeigt deutlich die
Bundesregierung entlastet junge Menschen
ganz massiv eine Sache das weiß ich aus
vielen Gesprächen und Nachrichten von
jungen Menschen die ist denen aber noch
wichtiger als die finanzielle
Unterstützung die wollen nämlich endlich
zur Schule gehen in die Unis gehen wie
das eigentlich gedacht ist die wollen
lernen die wollen mit inhaltlichen
Debatten in den Klassenzimmern in den
Vorlesungen in den Tutorien miteinander
streiten die wollen gemeinsam lernen den
Bibliotheken neue fachliche und
menschliche Erfahrungen sammeln das muss
wieder möglich sein und deswegen müssen
Schulen und Hochschulen offen bleiben
das ist ein Appell an die Universitäten
auch an die Länder und das ist deswegen
auch etwas was wir gemeinsam schaffen
müssen denn in den Ländern sind manchmal
die die Opposition hier sind in der
Regierung ich freue mich deswegen wenn
wir im Bildungsbereich alle an einem
Strang ziehen für die jungen Menschen in
unserem Land
so das war der kleine Serviceteil auch
hier von Seiten der FDP von Ria Schröder
man kann das übrigens auch
zu großen Teil Nachlesen auf
www.bundesregierung.de Entlastung für
Studierende da ist es im einzelnen auch
noch mal aufgelistet geht da konnte man
für die Union kommen wir doch mal vom
YouTube-Kanal den die Kollegin Schröder
gerade bedient hat zurück zum Plenum
denn ehrlicherweise sollten wir
miteinander sprechen und ich
übereinander und ich glaube dass eine
ernsthaft geführte Debatte ohne Polemik
tatsächlich mehr den Interessen der
Betroffenen gerecht wird denn
ehrlicherweise am Ende des Geldes ist
noch viel Monat übrig der Spruch ist
nicht neu schon vor der Krise war das
Thema Geld für viele Studenten und
Fachschüler tatsächlich
existenziell denn wir wissen sie fahren
mit ihren monatlichen Budgets immer
knapp auf Kante und deshalb schlägt die
Inflation doch bei ihnen besonders
gnadenlos zu das begann mit dem Preisen
für Lebensmittel jetzt Energie für
Wohnung die gehen wirklich auf dem
Zahnfleisch und zwar seit Monaten und
wer jetzt gerade die o sagt und diese
Einwürfe sind ja in dem Protokoll zu
leben der zeigt dass sie es nicht ernst
nehmen
das ist diese Polemik die die Menschen
umtreibt und am Ende Politik das
Vertrauen entzieht sagen wir doch wo wir
uns einig sind wir sind uns einig dass
Studenten und Fachschüler Hilfe brauchen
und zwar so schnell wie möglich denn
bislang wurden Studenten und Fachschüler
vergessen beim ersten Entlastungspaket
beim zweiten Entlastungspaket in dem
Füllhorn war für sie nichts dabei und da
habe ich manchmal den Eindruck sie
brauchen jetzt auch nicht zu zetern
beruhigen sie sich sondern kommen sie
aus ihrem
Paralleluniversum zurück in diese Welt
und in dieser Welt ist es so dass bei
der Energiepreis geldpauschale Studenten
und Fachschüler vergessen wurden sofern
sie kein Nebenjob hatten die anderen
sind leer ausgegangen und der
Heizkostenzuschuss 1 und ich würde
empfehlen bei Ausschusssitzung entweder
oder wie auch immer dabei zu sein dann
hätten sie in der letzten Woche gehört
dass ihr Staatssekretär Jens
Brandenburger gesagt hat dass es bei
sechs Prozent bislang erst angekommen
ist sie haben die bafög-debatte ins Feld
geführt aber seien Sie doch einmal
ehrlich ihre sogenannte
jahrhundert-reform hat eine
Halbwertszeit von Radon schnell
zerfallend das zeigt sich am sogenannten
notfallmechanismus mit Tamtam eingeführt
hilft aber jetzt keinen Betroffenen und
das haben sie selbst erkannt deshalb
jetzt beim Entlastungspaket drei eine
Einmalzahlung angekündigt das war am 4
September 2022 Kollegin Staffler hat
darauf hingewiesen seit 45 Tagen warten
Studenten und Fachschülerinnen wenn man
nicht weiß wie man Essen bezahlen soll
zählen nämlich Tage die Aussicht auf 200
Euro sind sicherlich nicht der große
Wurf aber 200 Euro würden eine kleine
Laufpause geben deshalb haben sich
Schüler und Studenten und Fachschüler
über das Versprechen der Regierung sehr
gefreut aber versprechen muss man
einlösen und deshalb fragen wir sie
jetzt alle in der Ampel wann kommt das
Geld auf dem Konto an nicht wann haben
Sie es in der Dienst die Antwort bleibt
die Regierung schuldig seit Wochen wir
haben in unterschiedlichen Gremien
gefragt wann wird das Geld ausgezahlt
wie die Antwort des BMBF man sucht nach
einer Lösung seit Wochen dafür wurde ein
Arbeitskreis eingesetzt liebe Frau
KommunistInnen stark Watzinger sie
hätten jetzt die Möglichkeit oder die
Ampel sich hier zu erklären welches
Gesetz wollen sie ändern wer soll die
auszahlende Stelle sein weshalb sollen
alle Studenten 200 Euro bekommen warum
machen sie es nicht bedarfsgerecht wieso
haben sie Meisterschüler ausgespart und
geht man so mit den Fachkräften von
morgen um
fragen über Fragen und keine Antworten
dieser Bundesregierung von Taten ganz zu
schweigen Leidtragenden sind Studierende
und Fachschüler ohne Frage und das ist
eine berechtigte Frage die Auszahlung
ist eine organisatorische
Herausforderung aber es geht wir standen
in der großen Koalition und die SPD möge
sich erinnern 2020 beider
Überbrückungshilfe für Studierende
ebenfalls unter enormen Druck
Studierende in pandemiebedingten
Notlagen konnten damals bis zu 500 Euro
beantragen
zuständig waren die regionalen
Studentenwerke es wurden seitens der
damaligen Bundesministerin Anja
Karliczek eine bundesweit einheitliche
IT-Plattform eingerichtet online
gestellt abgewickelt über die
Studentenwerke die
zusageankündigung erfolgte am 30 April
2020 40 Tage später konnte man die
Anträge stellen der Kollege Gehring hat
damals gesagt das sei trödeln wenn dies
Ihr Maßstab ist dann kann ich Ihnen nur
sagen wenn 45 Tage damals für Sie
trödeln war befindet sich ihre
Ministerin seit Wochen im vorgezogenen
Winterschlaf Kollegin vor diesem
Hintergrund werden sie Frau Kollegin sie
kommen zum Ende bitte jetzt lösen sie
ihr Versprechen ein bringt sie das Geld
zur Auszahlung vielen Dank
sagt Gitta Connemann von der
cdu/csu-fraktion
auch in Richtung natürlich der
zuständigen Ministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger die Bundesbildungsministerin
die hier auf der Regierungsbank dieser
Aussprache zuhört
Jens Pike für die SPD
sehr Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete im Antrag der CDU der
ist überschrieben mit den Worten wir
sollen Studierende Fachschule und
Fachschüler in der Krise unterstützen
das ist völlig richtig und völlig
unstrittig und es gibt hier niemanden
der das anders sieht
einig in unserem Land darf es nicht sein
dass die Studierende Fachschule und
Fachschüler zwischen warmer Wohnung oder
war Mittagessen entscheiden müssen
deshalb haben wir und deshalb haben wir
schon mehrfach gehört zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse einmal 230 und
einmal 345 Euro beschlossen deshalb
haben wir mit der bafög-reform unter
anderem ein nothilfe-mechanismus
geschaffen der greift für nichts anderes
mehr hilft und weil es als Unterstützung
nicht nur in der Krise braucht hat die
Koalition in Bafög Höchstsatz auf 934
Euro erhöht und wer neben dem Studium
arbeitet
was fast zwei Drittel der Studierenden
tun hat
die energiepreispauschale von 300 Euro
erhalten ebenso wie die meisten
Studentinnen und Studenten die Arbeiten
auch von der mindestlohnerhöhung von 12
Euro profitieren und jetzt im dritten
Entlastungspaket haben wir ausdrücklich
Studierende Fachschule und Fachschule
aufgenommen mit einer Einmalzahlung in
Höhe von 200 Euro und wenn Sie jetzt
hier behaupten die Bundeswehr
unterstütze
studentenfachschulfachschüler nicht
lasst sie im Regen stehen wie es bei ihm
Antrag heißt dann geht es ihnen weder um
die Studierenden hat man das Gefühle
oder eine Fachschule Fachschüler sondern
sie verunsichern hier die Menschen die
es geht um Frau Connemann das entzieht
der Politik vertrauen
sie unterstellen mir
wir würden einzelne Gruppen vergessen
werden und sie versuchen politischen
profitas die Situation zu schlagen das
wird ihrer staatspolitischen
Verantwortung glaube ich in dieser Lage
nicht gerecht
die Bundesregierung unterstützt und
entlastet und hilft an ganz vielen
Stellen mit allen zur Verfügung
stehenden Mitteln in der Breite der
Bevölkerung mit der Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes mit dem Wegfall der
EEG-Umlage mit einer Senkung der
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas der Ausweitung des
wohngelds oder mit dem neuen euro-ticket
alles zusätzliche Maßnahmen die in der
Breite der Bevölkerung wirken und auch
bei Studierenden Fachschülerinnen und
fachschülern denn für uns als Koalition
ist eins ganz klar
wir müssen und wir werden diese
Gesellschaft zusammenhalten niemanden in
diesem Land muss Sorge haben hinten
runter zu fallen
und sie kommen mit ihrer Forderung zu
spät und dann bleibt nicht mehr in ihrem
Antrag als zu sagen das was die
Regierung macht es gut aber sie müsste
es mal ein bisschen schneller tun ja
natürlich sind wir mit alle Maßnahmen so
schnell wie möglich umzusetzen sie
fordern eine zügige Auszahlung der 200
Euro je früher desto besser heißt es da
und sie unterstellen damit das würden
wir nicht tun
aber ich meine auch da ist es wieder
auch schon öfter in diesem Haus gesagt
aber notwendig vielleicht mal an andere
Aussagen von ihnen vor sechs Monaten zu
erinnern noch im März haben sie ein
gasendbarko gefordert dass uns
unvorbereitende Wirtschaftskrise
katapultierte da haben wir bereits das
erste Entlastungspaket auf dem Weg
gebracht
und im Sommer waren sie damit
beschäftigt massive Unterstützung mit
Waffen für Ukraine zu fordern haben wir
das zweite Entlastungspaket beschlossen
und jetzt haben wir das dritte
Entlastungspaket beschlossen und ein
Abwehrschirm gegensteigende Preise und
führen mit dem Bürgergeld ein
Sozialsystem eines die Menschen wieder
Vertrauen fassen können und ich sage das
so deutlich weil was machen sie das
gehört auch zu Debatte sie spielen beim
Bürgergeld geringverdienende gegen
Leistungsbezieher aus bei den
Entlastungen Rentner gegen Erwerbstätige
und jetzt Fachschule und Fachschüler
Studierende gegen den Rest liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der CDU ich
habe das Gefühl sie versuchen immer
weiter zu spalten und das bereitet mir
Sorge sagt das ganz deutlich und
deswegen sage ich hier wir als
Ampelkoalition stehen für
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und eins
eint uns in dieser Koalition dass wir es
dann fortschrittlich und sozialgerechter
machen wollen auch und gerade in dieser
Krise
und uns allen dass wir dafür
Verantwortung übernehmen
Verantwortung damit niemand frieren muss
weil es genug Gas gibt und das auch
bezahlbar ist für alle das verlangt uns
natürlich einiges ab und das ist nicht
immer einfach bei der Frage wie
russisches gasitz Energieträger setzen
wie mit Waffenlieferung Krisengebiete
umgehen oder auch wie was das mit dem
Haushalt macht aber alle drei
Regierungsverantwortung tun eins ohne
Wind aber sie übernehmen diese
Verantwortung und wir werden dieses Land
durch diese Krise tragen und das so
schnell natürlich wie es geht mit allen
Maßnahmen die ich gerade genannt habe
auch wenn staats-verantwortung auch
bedeutet es ordentlich durchzuführen den
Haushalt im Blick zu haben und es
verordnet auf dem Weg zu bringen
herzlichen Dank
Jens Kalk war das für die SPD-Fraktion
und als letzte Rednerin hier zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt hören wir jetzt die
Abgeordnete Marlene Schöneberger für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 grünen sitzt im
Ausschuss für Bildung und Forschung
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen der
demokratischen Fraktionen
ja eine Promotion abschließt hängt in
Deutschland noch immer massiv von den
finanziellen Möglichkeiten und dem
Bildungsweg der Eltern ab etwa 30
Prozent der Kinder aus nicht
akademischen Haushalten studieren bei
Akademiker in den Eltern sind es fast
dreimal so viele das nicht jeder Mensch
frei entscheiden kann wie Zukunft
aussehen soll weil diese Menschen an
finanzielle Grenzen stoßen das ist
ungerecht und undemokratisch und dagegen
kämpfen wir als Ampelkoalition mit allen
Mitteln
die Ungerechtigkeiten im Bildungsbereich
haben sich während der Pandemie noch
verstärkt in der Schule wurden gerade
die schüler:innen die es zuvor schon
schwer hatten weiter abgehängt und ein
Unis sieht es ähnlich aus ich brauche
nicht auszuführen zu welchen Krisen es
in der Pandemie geführt hat wenn der
Minijob weg und die Mensa geschlossen
war schon vor der Pandemie war ein
Drittel der Studierenden in Deutschland
von Armut betroffen das ist doppelt so
hoch wie in der Gesamtbevölkerung
gleichzeitig ist der Anteil der
bafög-bezieherinnen in den letzten
Jahren massiv gesunken die Förderung hat
längst nicht mehr alle erreicht die auf
sie angewiesen waren liebe Kolleginnen
von der Unionsfraktion es ist ein
vielsagender Zeitpunkt indem sie ihr
Herz für Studierende entdecken jetzt wo
sie in der Opposition sind sie hatten 16
Jahre Zeit im Bildungsministerium danke
dass Sie das Stichwort trödelministerin
noch mal genannt haben die prekäre
Situation vieler Studierender geht zu
großen Teilen auf Ihr Konto
diese Einmalzahlungen über die wir heute
sprechen ist natürlich nur ein Pflaster
in einer sozialen Notlage ist reicht
nicht wir sind seit fast einem Jahr
dabei die finanzielle Situation von
jungen Menschen langfristig zu
verbessern es wurde schon viel genannt
aber weil ich nach der letzten Union
Rede davon überzeugt bin dass es immer
noch nicht bei allen angekommen ist wir
sind gerade mitten in einer bafög-reform
wir haben bereits die Fördersätze
deutlich erhöht Menschen können länger
und Eltern unabhängiger beantragen im
Entlastungspaket 3 haben wir endlich
eine wichtige Lücke geschlossen wir
haben das Kindergeld angehoben und
Studierende auch ausländische mit
einbezogen nach den Entlastungen für
betriebliche ausbildende und Minijob
erinnern werden nur noch schüler:innen
und Auszubildenden Fachschulen
profitieren und auch das neun oder 49
euro-ticket und erhöhte Mindestlohn die
werden ganz besonders jungen Menschen
zugute kommen mit uns bleibt niemand
allein
ich finde es gut ich finde es gut dass
wir heute über die Situation junger
Menschen sprechen auch wenn ich nach
dieser Debatte bezweifle dass es allen
hier wirklich um junge Menschen geht
aber es stimmt es ist wichtig dass wir
die 200 Euro so schnell wie möglich
auszahlen wir werden niemanden vergessen
wir werden bürokratische Hürden
vermeiden aber das geht nicht von heute
auf morgen und alle die schon mal
regiert haben müssten das eigentlich
auch wissen
wir sind immer offen für konstruktive
Vorschläge und dieses Verfahren zu
beschleunigen aber dazu habe ich von
Ihnen heute nichts gehört und deswegen
lehnen wir Ihren Antrag ab vielen Dank
Schönenberger letzte Rednerin jetzt
hören wir mal die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin
wir kommen zu der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
40-44 mit dem Titel Studierende sowie
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler jetzt
in der Krise unterstützen 200 Euro
Zuschuss zügig auszahlen wer stimmt
dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich bei Enthaltung der
Fraktion DIE LINKE Zustimmung durch
cdu/csu und AFD gegen gestimmt haben die
koalitionsfraktion ist der Antrag
abgelehnt jetzt komme ich zum an zur
Abstimmung mit den Antrag der Fraktion
Die Linke auf Drucksache 4052 mit dem
Titel Unterstützung für Studierende und
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler
krisenfest gestalten nicht nur in diesem
Winter wer stimmt dafür
wer stimmt dagegen
fair enthält sich damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt zugestimmt hat die
einbringende Fraktionen aller anderen
haben den Antrag abgelehnt ich rufe
jetzt auch wieder die beiden Anträge von
der Union von der Linken die haben hier
keine Mehrheit gefunden das hatte sich
ja auch schon angedeutet in der Debatte
die Ampelkoalition hat das hier mit
ihrer Mehrheit abgewendet dass die 200
Euro diese energiepreispauschale zügig
bei den Studierenden ankommen sollen
darüber sind sich nun wirklich ja alle
einig das war hier natürlich kein
Diskussionspunkt es wird nach Wegen
gesucht wie man das ganze
bewerkstelligen kann wie das möglichst
schnell gehen soll die Ampel hat
bemängelt dass die Opposition ja auch
keine Vorschläge dazu vorlegen würde und
die Opposition hat bemängelt dass die
Ampel das eben nicht schnell genug
hinbekommen würde die Studenten werden
noch einen Moment darauf warten müssen
so viel scheint sicher denn das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren dazu zumindest
ist noch nicht
eingeleitet für die Rentner übrigens da
soll morgen die
Euro Energiepreis pauschale endgültig
beschlossen werden genauso wie auch und
das kommt dann zumindest einem Teil der
Studenten zugute ein zweiter
Heizkostenzuschuss in Höhe von 345 Euro
der morgen hier durch den Bundestag soll
so jetzt ganz schnell zum nächsten Tag
ist ordnungspunkt da steht schon die
Ministerin Nancy fazer es geht um das
neue Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
also Damen und Herren die
Bundesregierung hat sich nicht weniger
als ein Neustart in der
Migrationspolitik vorgenommen denn
Deutschland ist ein vielfältiges
Einwanderungsland und wir brauchen
endlich eine Politik die diesem Anspruch
auch gerecht wird
viel zu lange meine Damen und Herren
wurde Einwanderungen nach Deutschland
nicht aktiv gestaltet sondern
wiederwillig verwaltet man hat immer
neue bürokratische Hürden geschaffen die
viele gerade gut integrierte Menschen
verunsichert und frustriert haben damit
ist es jetzt Gott sei Dank vorbei denn
diese Koalition schafft ein modernes
Einwanderungsrecht meine Damen und
Herren
das ist eine große und komplexe Aufgabe
die wir in mehreren Schritten angehen
und den ersten Schritt machen wir heute
mit dem Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht wir
wollen dass Menschen die gut integriert
sind auch gute Chancen in Deutschland
haben deshalb geben wir Menschen die
seit mindestens fünf Jahren geduldet in
Deutschland leben für ein Jahr das
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht diese Zeit
können sie nutzen um die übrigen
Voraussetzungen für ein Bleiberecht zu
erfüllen dazu gehört vor allem dass sie
ihren Lebensunterhalt selbst bestreiten
dass sie Deutsch sprechen und dass sie
ihre Identität eindeutig nachweisen
können wenn alle Voraussetzungen erfüllt
sind erhalten diese Menschen ein
dauerhaftes Bleiberecht in Deutschland
wir geben Ihnen damit die Chance auch
die Zuversicht dauerhaft dazu zu gehören
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht ist das
Ende der kettendung und damit auch das
Ende der Bürokratie und der Unsicherheit
vor allen Dingen die damit für die
Menschen verbunden war für die
betroffenen Menschen war das eine große
Belastung aber auch für die Behörden
waren kettendungen schwierig und
übrigens auch für viele mittelständische
Unternehmen die gut integrierten
Menschen gerne ein Perspektive in
unserem Land geben wollen es ist
allerhöchste Zeit das zu ändern
ergänzend zum Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
bringen wir heute weitere Veränderungen
auf den Weg wir ermöglichen gut
integrierten jungen Menschen unter 27
Jahren schon nach drei Jahren ein
Bleiberecht wir erleichtern es den
Fachkräften die wir so dringend brauchen
ihre Familien mit nach Deutschland zu
bringen
Familienangehörige müssen künftig nicht
mehr nachweisen dass sie Deutsch
sprechen müssen das war übrigens in
allen anderen europäischen Ländern schon
länger der Fall und das ist mir sehr
wichtig wir sorgen für Integration von
Anfang an
AsylbewerberInnen Asylbewerber können
künftig schon während des laufenden
Asylverfahrens Sprach- und
Integrationskurse machen unabhängig von
einer bleiberechtsperspektive und das
ist auch gut so meine Damen und Herren
unsere Grundhaltung ist klar wer gut
integriert ist soll in Deutschland gute
Chancen haben umgekehrt gildebar auch
wer sich nicht an die Regeln hält
bekommt diese Chance nicht das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht gilt nicht für
Straftäter und es gilt nicht für
Personen die falsche Angaben über ihre
Identität machen im Gegenteil
Straftätern kann künftig leichter das
Aufenthaltsrecht entzogen werden wir
erleichtern auch die Anordnung von
Abschiebehaft damit sie vor ihrer
Abschiebung nicht untertauchen können
insofern ist das glaube ich auch gut so
meine Damen und Herren
die Grundlage für ein modernes
Einwanderungsland ist Klarheit klare
Chancen und genauso klare Regeln auf dem
Weg dahin machen wir mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht einen großen ersten
Schritt in die richtige Richtung und ich
darf mich bei allen bedanken die an
diesem Gesetz mitgearbeitet haben vielen
Dank
die Bundesinnenminister nennt sie Feser
war das ja die
ampelkoalitionspartner SPD Grüne und FDP
setzen ein zentrales
flüchtlingspolitisches Vorhaben aus
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag um mit diesem
sogenannten Chancen und Aufenthaltsrecht
wollen Sie also gut integrierten
Ausländern unter die Arme greifen die
schon mehrere Jahre ohne gesicherten
Status in Deutschland leben
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren wir beraten heute das erste
migrationspaket der Ampel zwei weitere
sollen folgen und die Ampel bezeichnet
das Gesetz selbst als Paradigmenwechsel
und meine Damen und Herren in der Tat es
handelt sich um einen Bruch mit einer
rechtsradition nämlich der
Unterscheidung einerseits zwischen dem
Asylrecht und andererseits der
allgemeinen migration
in christlicher Verantwortung und
humanitär ist es wichtig dass wir
verfolgten Menschen helfen und
Deutschland hat sein großes Herz in den
letzten Jahren unter Beweis gestellt und
tut das auch aktuell mit der Hilfe und
Unterbringung von rund eine Million
Menschen aus der Ukraine
es muss aber unser Anspruch sein und das
ist wichtig dass das Asylsystem nicht
missbraucht wird wenn nicht unsere
Gesellschaft und letztlich damit unser
Staat entscheidet wer zu uns kommt
sondern das in die Beliebigkeit eines
einzelnen gestellt wird dann geben wir
letztlich unsere Staatlichkeit auf und
damit auch die Ordnung und Steuerung die
Aufnahmefähigkeit unseres Landes müssen
wir den Menschen bereithalten die
tatsächlich verfolgt sind
die gesamtschutzquote
lag in den vergangenen Jahren bei
durchschnittlich 40 Prozent
der SPD-Kollege Hakan demia hat in einer
Debatte zutreffend gesagt dass da auch
formale Entscheidungen noch dazukommt
und auch Entscheidungen durch
gerichtsklageverfahren sind
hinzuzuziehen sie kommen auf 70%
und nehmen wir mal diesen 70 Prozent an
kommen wir zu den Zahlen zwischen 2015
und heute sind rund zwei Millionen
Menschen zu uns gekommen und haben
erstmalig ein Asylantrag gestellt wir
können rechnen
30 Prozent zwei Millionen Menschen das
heißt wir haben 600.000 Menschen die
unser System genutzt haben die die
Leistungen voll beansprucht haben und
das können wir uns wirklich nicht mehr
länger leisten meine Damen und Herren
das A und O ist ein funktionsfähiges
europäisches Asylsystem und ich rufe
Ihnen das heute auch noch mal zu von der
SPD und grün setzen Sie sich in Brüssel
dafür ein dass das grenzverfahren
welches die Kommission vorsieht mit
einer Vorprüfung kommt das ist das
einzige und wirksamste Mittel gegen ein
Missbrauch ganz wichtig
aber noch viel wichtiger ist natürlich
dass wir in Deutschland keine
Fehlanreize setzen und genau dies tut
der aktuelle Gesetzentwurf der die
Bezeichnung Ampel Amnestiegesetz
verdient hat belohnt werden gerade
diejenigen Ausländer die bislang nicht
abgeschoben werden konnten weil sie
entweder bei der Klärung der Identität
nicht mitgewirkt haben oder sogar aktiv
getäuscht haben und jetzt ist auch noch
das erklärte Ziel der Ampel den
Asylbewerbern aus Herkunftsstaaten die
regelmäßig gar keinen Anspruch haben
auch noch frühzeitig
Integrationsleistungen frühzeitig
Sprachkenntnis zukommen zu lassen und
sie haben es nicht verstanden spätestens
hier durch wird das deutliche Signal
gesetzt jeder kann kommen wer es
geschafft hat nach Deutschland zu kommen
wird auch bleiben und genau deshalb
lehnt die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion das
vorliegende Gesetz ab vielen Dank
Detlef Seif für die CDU CSU-Fraktion und
hat hier die Kritik formuliert erste
Beratung allerdings erst dieses
Gesetzentwurfes abgestimmt wird heute
noch nicht wir hören jetzt für die
Grünen die nächste Rednerin
Lamia Cador
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren
ich habe eine gute Nachricht wir sind im
Hier und Jetzt angekommen mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz gehen wir das
erste in einer Reihe von modernen
einwanderungsregelungen an und machen
Schluss mit einer Politik der Angst die
zurückliegenden Legislaturperioden waren
vor allem geprägt von Verschärfungen des
asyl- und Aufenthaltsrechts wir wenden
uns dem Thema dagegen mit einer
positiven Grundhaltung zu und gehen so
nichts weniger als eine
Paradigmenwechsel an
wir schauen auf die Chancen wir schauen
auf die Chance von Migration nicht nur
auf die Probleme wir stellen die Weichen
für einen Integrationspolitik der
Zukunft eine die um die Herausforderung
weiß die an Einwanderungsland mit sich
bringt und wir machen das gut und gerne
auch wenn es nicht leicht ist sobald das
Wort Migration fällt gibt es gibt es
Fragen
Ängste Sorgen dabei ist Migration eine
historische Normalität seit
Menschengedenken sie ist nichts
Außergewöhnliches die wie eine
Katastrophe über uns kommt nicht die
Migration ist häufig das Problem sondern
der Umgang damit meine Damen und Herren
schauen sie aber ins Land
wissen wir die Gesellschaft die Menschen
sind schon oft weiter viel weiter jede
vierte Person in diesem Land hat eine
internationale familienbiografie das
Thema wird stets benutzt für Populismus
es steckt voll von Angstmacherei Mythen
Halbwahrheiten und Lügen fragen Sie Herr
März wenn sie von der Union nun statt
vom sozialtourismus über sogenannte
pulfaktoren sprechen dann sollten wir
noch einmal klarstellen das Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz ich spreche sie gar
nicht an was auch egal das Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz lockt sicherlich
niemanden mehr hinter dem Ofen hervor
nämlich erstmal zwölf Jahre in der
Duldung zu leben möglicherweise die
Familie nicht hier zu haben und danach
ein Jahr lang Probe auf Probe Teil
dieser Gesellschaft zu sein es geht also
darum Menschen die bereits hier sind
diese Chance zu geben die
süßmut-kommission hat im übrigen in
ihrem Bericht im Jahre 2001 die
Abschaffung der kettendung gefordert das
ist jetzt 21 Jahre her und nun machen
wir endlich einen großen Schritt in die
richtige Richtung
ich komme aus Duisburg und wir sind
Industriestadt spreche ich vor Ort mit
Vertretern Vertretern der Stahlbranche
oder der IHK kommen zahlreiche Beispiele
von gut ausgebildeten Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeitern die plötzlich in der
Abschiebung landen nachdem sie um ihre
Unternehmen sich um Arbeitsplatz
Arbeitsplatz Wohnung oder
Kinderbetreuung gekümmert haben das hier
das können wir uns nicht mehr leisten
weder moralisch noch wirtschaftlich
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht erhalten
geduldete Personen die seit fünf Jahren
straffrei in Deutschland leben endlich
eine menschenrechtskonforme Perspektive
das betrifft über 240.000 Menschen deren
Asylanträge abgelehnt wurden die aber
auch nicht in ihrer Heimat zurück in
ihre Heimat zurückkehren können weil
dort beispielsweise Krieg herrscht die
Taliban oder Diktatoren herrschen und
regieren das bedeutet sie sind in der
Regel für wenige Monate vor einer
Abschiebung geschützt danach wird erneut
geprüft diese entwürdigende Praxis
werden wir gemeinsam in der Ampel
endlich beenden
mit diesem Aufenthaltsrecht auf Probe
haben die Betroffenen die Chance die
Voraussetzung für eine
Aufenthaltserlaubnis auf Dauer zu
erbringen das ist ein lang ersehnter
Meilenstein in der Asylpolitik denn
damit ermöglichen wir einen Spurwechsel
Menschen die seit Jahren in Deutschland
leben aber bisher kein Asyl erhalten
haben bekommen eine Chance ganz nebenbei
gewinnen wir somit auch 10.000
motivierte Arbeitskräfte die unser Land
so dringend benötigt mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht leisten wir also einen
Beitrag ja Sie können so lange
reinschreiben wie Sie wollen das nützt
ihn nur nichts mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht leisten wir also einen
Beitrag gegen den Arbeitskräftemangel
gerade Handwerksbetriebe gerade
Handwerksbetriebe und mittelständische
Unternehmen werden von der Neuregelung
profitieren viele Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber müssen sich nicht mehr
fragen ob Ihre Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter mit Duldung womöglich von
heute auf morgen abgeschoben werden
müssen und 130.000 Menschen die länger
als fünf Jahre hier leben und geduldet
sind können direkt von dieser Regelung
profitieren viele geduldete die
jahrelangen Angst vor einer Abschiebung
leben mussten erhalten endlich die
Chance auf ein dauerhaftes Bleiberecht
und zu einem pragmatischen Verfahren im
Aufenthaltsrecht gehört dann eben auch
das Prinzip Ausbildung statt Abschiebung
eine Win-Win-Situation für alle
Beteiligten
am Ende noch ein Wort zu all jenen jetzt
sind sie mal dran am Ende ein Wort noch
zu all jene die Migration für rechten
Populismus besprochen also fühlen Sie
sich ruhig angesprochen als weiteren
großen Schritt braucht es ein gut
funktionierendes Einwanderungsgesetz wie
ist die Ampelkoalition ebenso anstoßen
wird und deshalb werden wir unter
anderem das staatsangehörigkeits sowie
das Familien als auch das
Einwanderungsrecht reformieren wir
wollen auch das asyl-prozessrecht
reformieren und damit auch die
unabhängige asylverfahrensberatung
einführen wir verstehen Vielfalt als
Chance und gleichzeitig als Ressource
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
und ja wir wissen um die krisenhafte
Zeiten der wir uns gerade befinden aber
die Bewältigung dieser Zeit auf Kosten
von Humanität ist für uns inakzeptabel
und menschenverachtend
ich freue mich also dass wir in der
Gegenwart angekommen sind und uns
endlich zu unserem Einwanderungsland
bekennen einfach weil wir eines sind
vielen Dank
wer am 1 Januar 2022 fünf Jahre in
Deutschland gelebt hat und nicht
straffällig geworden ist soll nach dem
Vorstellung der Ampelkoalition ein
Aufenthaltsrecht erhalten hat dann ein
Jahr Zeit die Voraussetzung für eine
reguläres Bleiberecht zu erfüllen
sehr geehrte Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren das neue Gesetz dass die
Bedingungen für eine
Aufenthaltserlaubnis aufweicht hat den
Zweck abgelehnter Asylbewerber die
trotzdem unter einer Reihe bekannter
Vorwände nicht abgeschoben werden
geduldet werden nun nach fünf Jahren
endgültig Deutschland aufzubürden dieser
sogenannte chancenaufenthalt soll
Deutschland endgültig die Chance nehmen
Asylbetrüger irgendwann auch mal wieder
loszuwerden was sind die Bausteine
dieser Ruchlosigkeit bei der Aufrechnung
dieser Mindestaufenthaltsdauer waren
bislang Zeiten nicht enthalten in denen
der nur geduldete Migrant der also
keinen asylgrundnachweis seine Identität
gegebenenfalls verschleiert womit er das
eigentlich angezeigte abschiebezielland
verheimlicht diese Zeiten der bewussten
Verschleierung der eigenen Identität
wenn künftig als warteleistung auf der
Uhr bis zur dauerhaften
Aufenthaltserlaubnis angerechnet
überhaupt soll künftig ungeklärte
Identität Hindernis mehr sein wahrlich
ein Fortschritt nur nicht für
Deutschland nur nicht für Freunde der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit meine Damen und
Herren
im gleichen Sinne werden noch weitere
Hürden für die Aufenthaltserlaubnis
geschleift hat man sich einfach einer
geplanten Abschiebung durch zeitweise
des Untertauchen entzogen so war das
früher ein No-Go ab sofort aber kein
Problem mehr Rechtsbrecher werden von
dieser Regierung belohnt das ist nur
konsequent wo es darum geht abgelehnte
Asylbewerber also Leute ohne Asylgrund
hierzulande trotz allem zu verstetigen
da ist Fluchtpunkt aller Regelungen
natürlich der Erfolg der Täuschung der
Lohn der Lüge meine Damen und Herren
warum etwa sollen Asylbewerber bis 27
schon nach drei Jahren hier in den
permanenten Aufenthalt übergehen ganz
einfach Asyl und Klageverfahren dauern
typischerweise gerade etwas länger so
wird hier just bevor ein Gericht über
das tatsächliche bestehen oder nicht
Bestehen des schutzanspruchs geurteilt
hat noch eilig ein Aufenthaltsrecht
gezimmert das Urteil des Rechtsstaats
könnte da womöglich stören
Integrationskurse sollen bislang
natürlich nicht finanziert werden für
Fälle absehbarer nicht Anerkennung etwa
für Bewerber aus sicheren
Herkunftsländern auch hier sollen nun
integrationstatbestände auf dem Papier
ermöglicht werden offensichtlich
einziger Zweck nachfolgend dann die
eigentlich kontraindizierte Anerkennung
doch noch irgendwie durchzudrücken
während die Deutschen sich das Heizen
nicht mehr leisten können wird ihr
Steuergeld für illegale verheizt
und der von der Regierung zur
Legitimierung von Unrecht immer gerne
beigebrachte
argumentationspass partout eines
Fachkräftemangels ist bei
millionenfacher europäischer
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit und einer
viertelmillionen arbeitslosen
anerkannten Asylbewerbern plus 400.000
Erwerbs für eu-krainer natürlich ein
Witz allerdings ein schlechter ja
eigentlich eine Verhöhnung aller dieser
normalen Arbeitslosen denen hier
ausgerechnet importierte Asylbetrüger
gegebenenfalls vorgezogen würden Chancen
Aufenthalt die Regierung nimmt hier
allein die sich abgelehnte Ausländer ein
die eine Chance haben sich in
Deutschland gut gehen zu lassen die
Prioritäten sind klar deutsche
Interessen sind es nicht übrigens wollen
Sie denn Menschen in ein Land locken wo
Energie und Wohnraum knapp bis nicht
vorhanden sind wo nicht mehr geheizt und
nur noch kalt geduscht werden darf wenn
es nach den Grünen geht ähnelt das nicht
jeden Menschen und würde in Bedingungen
deren Gerichte Abschiebungen etwa nach
Griechenland verbieten die Stellungnahme
des landkreistags bestätigt dass der
betroffene Personenkreis kein Interesse
an der Füllung der gesetzlichen
Mitwirkungspflicht habe oder sich jemals
ernsthaft integrieren wolle verweilt und
in Deutschland sei ausschließlich
wirtschaftliche vorteilsname aber statt
auf feministische Außenpolitik setzt
Frau Feser eher auf antifeministische
Innenpolitik und will Zuwanderergruppen
unbedingt im Land belassen die
überproportional oft Gewalt und
Sexualdelikte verüben man fragt sich
langsam produziert die Ampel in der
Energie-
Informationspolitik haben diese Chancen
gehen alle nur zu Lasten Deutschlands
meine Damen und Herren und deshalb muss
es dabei bleiben keine
Laufzeitverlängerung für illegale ich
danke Ihnen
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Stefan Tobi das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach so viel
schrillen Tönen will ich doch noch mal
versuchen herauszustellen
herauszuarbeiten worin die Chancen
bestehen und worin der Paradies im
Wechsel eigentlich besteht die Kondition
plant wir wollen in Zukunft mehr
reguläre Immigration und weniger
irreguläre Migration bei uns haben eine
Zukunft wollen wir eine klare Trennung
haben wer benötigt Schutz und Hilfe von
uns der soll sie auch bei uns finden
wer sucht eigentlich Arbeit oder
Ausbildung bei uns dem wollen wir ein
besseres Angebot unterbreiten denn der
Bedarf an Arbeitskräften bei uns ist
groß
aber auf wen trifft wieder das eine noch
das andere zu dann müssen wir auch
konsequent auf der Ausreise bestehenden
nötigenfalls auch konsequenter als
bislang durchsetzen das ist der
Paradigmenwechsel
das Problem ist dass in der
Vergangenheit diese klare Trennung und
diese konsequente Umsetzung eben nicht
stattgefunden hat und deswegen leben
zurzeit
136.000 Menschen in diesem Land seit
mehr als fünf Jahren in einem
duldungsstatus bei uns hängen im
Sozialsystem fest verlieren auch selbst
und vor ihren Kindern an Selbstachtung
gewinnen nie die Akzeptanz und die
Anerkennung der Menschen in diesem Land
sie sind mit einem Wort nie so richtig
angekommen und gleichwohl reisen sie
seit Jahren auch nicht aus und auch
ihnen ist es nie gelungen die Ausreise
durchzusetzen
das sind Menschen deren Kinder besser
Deutsch sprechen als die Sprache ihre
Eltern und Großeltern den eigentlich
viel
Integrationspotenzial steckt und diese
Potenziale zu heben das muss doch unsere
Aufgabe sein wir wollen dass diese
Menschen
dann eben auf eigenen Beinen stehen dass
sie ihr Leben auch bei uns selber in die
Hand nehmen mit einem Wort meine Damen
und Herren wir wollen aus
Hilfeempfängern
Steuerzahler machen in diesem Land
in Vergangenheit kosten sie uns Geld wir
wollen dass Sie einen Beitrag leisten
können zum Gelingen unserer Gesellschaft
das ja auch würde wiederfinden können
aber natürlich bekommt man nichts auf
der Welt einfach so geschenkt das hat
Voraussetzungen man muss sich straffrei
bei uns im Land Verhalten die Identität
muss geklärt sein muss wirtschaftlich
auf eigenen stehen können und wem das
eben nicht gelingt der fällt nach einem
Jahr wieder in den duldungsstatus zurück
und muss dann ebenfalls ausreißen in
Zukunft wollen wir eben nicht mehr und
das ist der andere Teil für uns
notwendiger zugehört wir wollen das in
Zukunft nicht mehr Hunderttausende von
Menschen jahrelang geduldet sind und
deswegen gehört zum chancenaufenthalt
auch noch eine zweite Komponente hinzu
die auch noch kommen wird und die
Vorbereitung ist beim Innenministerium
nämlich die Verfahrensbeschleunigung das
ist ein Teil ein integraler Teil unseres
Paketes wir wollen das Glück eben nicht
mehr jahrelang Menschen in diesen
Bildungsstatus verharren und deswegen
muss auch Ausreise unnötigen was
Abschiebung konsequent umgesetzt werden
deswegen ist im Paket auch enthalten
dass sie Abschiebehaft verlängert wird
um die Abschiebungen besser möglich zu
machen das ist unsere Kombination aus
Humanität die wir ernst nehmen und
wollen aber auch Kontrolle die auch dazu
gehört meine Damen und Herren
und ich finde es deswegen Herr Kollege
seiff auch unzutreffend wenn sie sagen
wir setzen Fehlanreize weil ihr auch
eine klaren Stichtag setzen der
chancenaufenthalt der heute eingebracht
wird wirkt nämlich nur in die
Vergangenheit es wird ein Stichtag
versehen nämlich mit dem ersten Januar
2022 vor dem zurückwirkend auf fünf
Jahre jemand im Land sein muss er wird
also nicht in die Zukunft und Anreize
können doch nur eine Zukunft wirken und
deswegen finde Diagnose unzutreffend
Herr Kollege Seif und
weil auch das gerade noch gesagt worden
ist es kommen ja doch dadurch auch nicht
mehr Menschen ins Land wir sprechen von
Menschen die schon da sind die seit
Jahren hier bei uns im System hängen und
das sind deswegen auch nicht die
Menschen die Turnhallen auffüllen
sondern wir meinen die Menschen die hier
sind und die wir doch eigentlich
brauchen Menschen die hier einen Beitrag
leisten davon profitieren die
Verbraucher wir erleben doch Tag für Tag
dass Menschen im Dienstleistungsberufen
fehlen im Verkauf einen Flughäfen im
Handwerk davon profitieren die
Arbeitgeber weil es sie nicht mehr
gelingt Arbeitskräfte zu finden
Ausbildungsplätze zu besetzen dann
profitieren natürlich die geduldigten
selber und vor allem auch der Staat denn
jetzt kosten diese Menschen und künftig
sollen Sie etwas beitragen und deswegen
gibt es viele viele Gründe das was wir
heute einbringen auch zu beschließen
voranzubringen und deswegen ist ein
gutes Gesetz für das ich mich beim BMI
auch herzlich bedanke
sagt Stefan Tomé für die FDP-Fraktion ja
die Stichtagsregelung also erst Januar
2022 das war auch der FDP wichtig das
soll also so deswegen wird das
Aufenthaltsrecht lediglich sogenannte
Altfälle wird treffen allerdings gibt es
an dieser Stichtagsregelung auch
durchaus innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
Kritik jetzt werden wir für die Linke
Clara Bünger
Migration in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
gelesen habe war ich erstmal positiv
überrascht nach einem Jahr muss ich aber
feststellen von dem groß angekündigten
Neustart in der Migrationspolitik so wie
sie es auch gesagt haben Frau Ministerin
kann keine Rede sein diese Kritik kommt
nicht nur von mir auch viele
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation sind
enttäuscht der viel zu unambitionierte
Gesetzentwurf für ein Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht zeigt deutlich wo die
Probleme liegen laut Koalitionsvertrag
wollen sie eigentlich Menschen aus der
Kettenbildung rausholen mit dem jetzigen
Vorschlag bekommen aber wie die
Bundesregierung selber schätzt nur etwa
34.000 Menschen ein dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht das sind nicht besonders
viele gegenüber den mehr als 240.000
Personen die nur eine Duldung haben und
die eigentlich einen Aufenthaltstitel
bräuchten
sollen diese Menschen etwa keine Chance
erhalten die Anforderung für das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht sind außerdem viel zu
hoch zum Beispiel wird erwartet dass
Betroffene nach einem Jahr ihren
Lebensunterhalt sichern und das nachdem
sie über Jahre hinweg systematisch
ausgegrenzt und vom Arbeitsmarkt
ferngehalten wurden
hier bräuchte es
Verlängerungsmöglichkeiten das gleiche
gilt auch beim Spracherwerb
enttäuschend ist außerdem dass sie den
Gesetz dass sie in dem Gesetzentwurf
nicht nutzen um die identitätsklärung
per eidesstattlicher Versicherung
einzuführen das verstehe ich wirklich
nicht weil es in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
so drinsteht und wenn Sie es wirklich
ernst meinen würden müsste das Gesetz
stichtagsunabhängig gelten nur so würde
wirklich allen langjährig geduldeten
Menschen der Übergang in ein dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht eröffnet
und ich werde das Gefühl nicht los dass
sie sich von Friedrich Merz und Co
treiben lassen kurz nachdem er von
sozialtourismus gesprochen hatte legte
Innenministerin Fezer nach und sprach
sich für eine weitere Abschottung der
Grenzen aus
illegale Migration müsse gestoppt werden
so sieht doch kein Paradigmenwechsel in
der Migrationspolitik aus die Worte der
Innenministerin klingt für mich eher wie
eine Fortsetzung der Politik von
Seehofer
und dabei ist vieles was im
Koalitionsvertrag steht richtig zum
Beispiel die Erleichterung beim
Familiennachzug aber die müssen sie auch
endlich umsetzen
zig Verschärfung ich glaube es waren 15
die in den letzten Jahren durchgezogen
wurden sind nach wie vor in Kraft das
darf so nicht bleiben deshalb fordern
wir auch in unserem Antrag das in einem
ersten Schritt die seit 2015
vorgenommenen Verschärfung im
abschiebungsverfahren zurückgenommen
werden müssen das betrifft insbesondere
überraschungsabschiebung ohne
Vorankündigung und den Umgang mit
psychisch und physisch kranken Menschen
vielen Dank
klar Bünger war das für die
Linksfraktion jetzt hören wir für die
Sozialdemokraten deren
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der Krise
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei dem heute
eingebrachten Gesetz zum Chancen
Aufenthalt handelt es sich nicht um
einen Paradigmenwechsel sondern es
handelt sich um die Anerkennung von
Lebensrealitäten bei uns im Land die
leider von unserem letzten
Koalitionspartner viel zu lange
verleugnet worden sind und darum ist es
ein guter Tag für viele Menschen bei uns
im Land die bereits lange hier sind die
Teil unserer Mitte sind die in unserer
Mitte in Dörfern in Stadtteilen gut
integriert sind und diese Menschen
wollen wir aus dieser Unsicherheit der
kettendungen herausholen Ihnen eine
klare Perspektive geben und in eine
klare Perspektive gegen dass Sie zu uns
in diesem Land dazuhören und das ist gut
dass wir das heute gemeinsam auf den Weg
gehen
und ich will das ausdrücklich sagen und
ich bin dem Bundesinnenministerium der
Bundesministerin nennt sich Weser aber
auch den Koalitionsfraktionen von grünen
FDP aber natürlich auch bei uns in der
Sozialdemokratie dankbar dass wir das
gemeinsam auf den Weg gebracht hat weil
es wirklich gut integrierten Menschen
bei uns im Land eine klare Perspektive
gibt und ich will das deutlich sagen es
sind doch die Beispiele die wir alle bei
uns aus den Wahlkreisen kennen es sind
die Meldungen die wir plötzlich in der
Tagespresse erleben dass jemand
abgeschoben werden soll der lange im
Handwerksunternehmen nebenan gearbeitet
hat der im Wirtschaftsbetrieb gearbeitet
hat und plötzlich aus der Mitte seiner
belegschaftskollegen herausgerissen wird
es sind die Kinder die letztendlich
plötzlich morgens aus der Schule
herausgenommen werden weil sie in
Kettenduldung in dieser Unsicherheit
gelebt werden und diesen Menschen die
hier sind diese Perspektive zu geben es
ist richtig und ich will es mal deutlich
sagen genau diese Fälle sind es doch
letztendlich wo auch Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus der Unionsfraktion dann
Briefe schreiben sich beschweren das ist
doch nicht sein kann und heute
verleugnen sie diese Lebensrealitäten da
kann ich ganz ehrlich gesagt nur über
den Kopf schon
und ich will das auch noch mal
unterstreichen es geht um diejenigen die
länger als fünf Jahre hier gewesen sind
die nicht straffällig geworden sind
denen wir jetzt genau diese Chance
einräumen dazu beizutragen dass sie den
Lebensunterhalt sichern aufklären auch
über die Entität wo es noch Unklarheiten
letztendlich gibt und die dann die klare
Chance und Perspektive geben weiterhin
Teil unserer Mitte letztendlich auch zu
sein und das werden wir jetzt auch im
parlamentarischen Verfahren auch
gemeinsam voranbringen aber es ist
völlig richtig es ist nur ein Teil der
Vorhaben die wir letztendlich auch in
der Ampelkoalition voranbringen wollen
es geht auch in die Beschleunigung der
Asylverfahren es geht auch um die
Modernisierung des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts und es geht
um ein modernes Einwanderungsrecht für
dieses Land was wir dringend brauchen
und dass wir eigentlich schon längst
hätten haben müssen und das wollen wir
jetzt Ampelkoalition auch gemeinsam
voranbringen
und ich sag's auch ganz deutlich zum
Abschluss genauso gut ist es richtig den
Zugang zu Integrationskursen bereits von
Beginn an zu öffnen um Grundwerte
unserer Verfassung zu vermitteln
Grundwerte zu vermitteln über Recht und
Kultur und ich kann Ihnen nur eins sagen
Herr kurio nutzen Sie so ein
Integrationskurs auch mal für sich als
Chance es kann doch mal Grundlagen
unserer Verfassung vermitteln und es
kann hier engstirniges zwölfjähriges
Geschichtsverständnis vielleicht auch
noch mal überholen in diesem Sinne ein
gutes Gesetz was wir voranbringen
sagt dirkwiese hier für die SPD-Fraktion
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für innen und Heimat der Subtraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin und
Kollegen die Ampel schafft ein
Amnestiegesetz für Menschen die
ausreisepflichtig sind die hier keinen
Schutzanspruch haben keinen
schutzbedürfen sondern rechtskräftig
ausreisepflichtig sind und das hat auch
nichts mit Humanität zu tun weil denen
die Schutz brauchen den geben wir hier
diesen Schutz auch und liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen der Ampel sie führen die
Menschen schlichtweg in die Irre mit
ihrem sogenannten chancenaufenthalt
nützen sie nur einer Personengruppe
unter den geduldeten nämlich denen ohne
geklärte Identität alle anderen
geduldeten haben heute schon die
Möglichkeit zu arbeiten und spätestens
nach sechs bis acht Jahren ihren
Daueraufenthalt zu bekommen nur die ohne
geklärte Identität die ihren Pass nicht
vorlegen von denen wir nicht wissen
woher sie kommen und wie sie heißen
denen ermöglichen sie die das
Bleiberecht und dann kommt im zweiten
migrationspaket Frau Ministerin mit
Sicherheit die eidesstattliche Erklärung
und dann genau diese Personengruppe
sagen kann ich heiße so und so und ich
komme da und daher und dann müssen wir
das glauben das ist ein großes
Sicherheitsrisiko und sie führen die
Menschen hier in die Irre Herr Kollege
Thome
und natürlich Stichtag wirkt rückwirkend
ja für die Zukunft brauchen sie das gar
nicht mehr weil sie schaffen ja weitere
bleiberechte für Erwachsene aber
insbesondere für sogenannte Jugendliche
und jugendlich ist man nach der Ampel im
aufenthaltsrechtlichen sind zukünftig
bis zum zarten Alter von 27 Jahren bis
27 Jahren kann das Privileg genutzt
werden als sogenannter Jugendlicher hier
ein Bleiberecht zu erhalten das ist
wirklich keine geordnete
Migrationspolitik liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wenn man weiß dass 2021 73
Prozent aller Asylanträge von Menschen
bis 29 so ist die Statistik halt
gestellt wurden dann wissen Sie was dies
für eine Öffnung hier in Deutschland
bedeutet für die Zukunft liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sie wollen dass es zukünftig heißt jeder
der irgendwie nach Deutschland kommt
kann auch hier bleiben egal ob er
Schutzanspruch hat oder nicht und Herr
Kollege Thomas
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin und schöne
Sache Herr Kollege dass sie die Frage
zulassen wir ermöglichen mit dem
chancenter Aufenthaltsrechts 130.000
Menschen in diesem Land eine echte
Perspektive die hier eine Perspektive
suchen und wir beide wir kommen aus dem
gleichen wirtschaftsstarken Bundesland
Baden-Württemberg und stellen da an
allen Orten fest dass wir einen heftigen
Personalmangel haben egal ob es beim
Handwerker ist beim Friseur oder in der
Gießerei oder in der Härterei überall
gibt es
Fachkräftemangel Arbeitskräftemangel und
meine Frage an Sie wäre wenn ich bei mir
mit Betrieben spreche dann höre ich
immer wieder dass sie das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht gut finden auch die IHK
hat ausdrücklich gesagt dass das eine
gute Sache ist und in meinem Wahlkreis
gibt es immer wieder Betriebe die es
auch gut finden dass damit wirklich
Menschen die nur geduldet sind die eine
Werkbank stehen damit bleiben können und
dauerhaft ihren Arbeitsplatz behalten
und damit auch den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland oder bei uns
Baden-Württemberg unterstützen meine
Frage an Sie wir sie in ihrem Wahlkreis
auch solche Betriebe Herr Kollege ich
habe die Diskussionen auch aber bei mir
im Wahlkreis werden Fachkräfte gesucht
das ist nicht die Personengruppe und die
es heute in ihrem Gesetz geht sie
schaffen damit sie schaffen damit
sie schaffen damit Anreize für un- und
minder qualifizierte und das ist nicht
das Personen Klientel des zukünftig
unsere Volkswirtschaft und unsere
Betriebe rettet und deswegen ist das das
völlig falsche Signal dass sie hier
aussehen und Herr Kollege auch was der
tome gesagt hat man möge jetzt legale
Wege schaffen damit man nicht mehr
illegal nach Deutschland kommen müsste
glauben Sie denn wirklich dass wenn sie
wie mit diesem Gesetz
zusätzliche dann zukünftig legale Wege
schaffen dass dann die anderen irgendwo
auf der Welt sagen oh die Ampel hat
jetzt hier legale Wege geschafft ich
weil da aber nicht runter dann bleibe
ich mal zu Hause sitzen die kommen
zusätzlich sie schaffen weitere Anreize
insbesondere die FDP ist hier
irreführend bei ihrem Wähler Klientel
unterwegs Herr Kollege Thomas aus meiner
Heimatstadt Heilbronn Heilbronn
kommt kam Theodor Heuss wir haben eine
lange liberale Tradition wenn ich aber
mit Menschen in meinem Wahlkreis die
auch der FDP zuneigen spreche über
dieses Gesetz und sie aufkläre was da
wirklich drinsteht dann haben sie kein
Verständnis sie machen das Projekt 5%,
aber von oben nach unten sie arbeiten an
ihren Wählerinnen und Wähler vorbei und
letzte Bemerkung
rückführungsoffensive
das ist eine Fass weil in dieses Gesetz
umgesetzt wird dann bleiben zum Schluss
nur noch Straftäter übrig die
abgeschoben werden müssen alle anderen
gewähren sie dauerhafte bleiberechte
herzlichen Dank
Kritik von Alexander droben hier aus der
CDU CSU-Fraktion
da liegen die Positionen sehr weit
auseinander
jetzt hören wir als fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten Robert vale
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren das
Chancen und Aufenthaltsrecht ist nichts
anderes als die schrittweise
Legalisierung
illegaler Migration
anstatt die geltende Rechtslage nach
abgelehntem Asylantrag mit Abschiebungen
auch durchzusetzen kommt ein Gesetz das
über die Zeitschiene den gültigen
Rechtsrahmen endgültig aushebelt ein
beispielloser Fall dass der Bundestag
mit einer neuen Gesetzgebung bestehendes
Recht aushebelt selbst aushebel das ist
so das ist so als ob man jemand ohne
Ticket einen Zug sitzt und wenn der
Schaffner kommt heißt es der
Schwarzfahrer ist schon so lange im Zug
gefahren dass er sich das Recht auf eine
legale Weiterfahrt erworben hat die
Kette lautet auf die igeler illegale
Einreise folgt ein abgelehnter
Asylbescheid dann folgt die Duldung mit
Arbeitserlaubnis dann der Einstieg in
Hartz IV dann ein Bleiberecht und
schließlich kommt die Einbürgerung und
das Wahlrecht eine Kurzbeschreibung von
Deutschland im Jahr 22 lautet wer Geld
hat der wandert aus wer kein Geld hat
der wandert ein und zwar in unserer
Sozialsystem warum kommen die
hochqualifizierten Fachkräfte nicht zu
uns zu der Sprachbarriere kommen die
niedrigen Verdienstmöglichkeiten die
vergleichsweise niedrigen Bruttolöhne
treffen auf die höchsten Steuern
Sozialabgaben in der Welt kommen Sie
bitte
industrialisierungspolitik der Ampel
meine Damen und Herren lehnen Sie diesen
Gesetzentwurf ab weil er Deutschland
endgültig vor die Wand feiert vielen
Dank
machen sie es nicht
im Deutschen Bundestag gibt es derzeit
fünf fraktionslose Abgeordnete 4 von
ihnen gehörten ehemals zur afd-fraktion
wie beispielsweise Robert farle Helge
Lindt jetzt für die SPD der zuständige
Berichterstatter für die SPD-Fraktion zu
diesem Gesetzentwurf Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
welchen Sinn macht es eine sechsstellige
Zahl von Personen rechtschaffen gut
integriert
jahrelang manchmal sogar jahrzehntelang
seit Geburt in einem Zustand der
Unsicherheit zu lassen teilweise
abhängig von sozialsicherungsleistungen
mit Arbeitgebern wenn Sie den Arbeiten
können die in demselben
unsicherheitszustand sind ohne
sicherheitspolitischen Mehrwert ohne
Mehrwert für die identitätsklärung und
ohne realistische Perspektive der
Rückkehr welchen Sinn macht das Klaus
macht keinen Sinn welchen Sinn macht die
Fortschreibung einer Blockade und eines
Selbstbetrugs keinen Sinn und deshalb
ist dieser Moment durchaus ein
historischer und deshalb bin ich
ausgesprochen dankbar für den
Gesetzentwurf der Ministerin und wir
werden als Koalition diesen
Gesetzentwurf durchbringen und damit
endlich ein Gesetz des gesunden
Menschenverstandes hier durchsetzen denn
darum geht es hier
die Menschen um die es geht
wir haben nicht als agend eine große
migrationspolitische Fragen oder open
borders oder sonst wie ihre Agenda ist
ihr eigenes Leben sie wollen einfach ihr
vernünftig leben können denn sie sind
Mitglied dieser Gesellschaft aber bisher
dürfen Sie jetzt nicht sein und das ist
der Skandal an dem wir arbeiten und den
wir ändern werden
wir zeigen mit diesem Chancen Aufenthalt
der eine Brücke ist in einer
verbessertes Bleiberecht das eben
Pragmatismus oft auch der bessere
Idealismus ist und gleichzeitig zeigen
wir dass ihre pulfaktor Ideologie
absoluter Blödsinn ist pull Faktor macht
nur in der Hinsicht Sinn dass ihr
dauerhaftes geredet ich spreche auch von
der CDU und allen anderen die das tun
der pulfaktor ist für Wählerstimmen der
AFD das ist der einzige funktionierende
pulfaktor in diesen Zusammenhang wir
aber tun etwas was sowohl
volkswirtschaftlich als auch
migrationspolitisch als auch
integrationspolitisch als auch humanitär
und hören Sie genau zu
Sicherheitspolitik sinnvoll ist und
Fortschritte bringt und fundamentale
Fortschritte bringt und dann
kommen wir ich bin ja immer allergisch
was doppeltsügigkeiten und wie Batterien
betrifft kommen wir doch zur CDU sie
sprachen ja wiederholt Herr Seif Herr
Trum vom Ampel Amnestiegesetz ich würde
es eher das CDU amnesiegesetz nennen
warum
ihr eigener Ministerpräsident des
bevölkerungsreichsten Bundeslandes in
dem die meisten geduldeten Leben
zugleich auch Landesvorsitzender der CDU
des größten Landesverbandes der CDU
fordert explizit im Koalitionsvertrag
der von ihm geführten Regierung ich
zitiere alle humanitären und
aufenthaltssichernden
Bleiberechtsregelung so auszuschöpfen
dass gut integrierte geflüchtete
geduldete bleiben können und erfordert
uns explizit auf
explizit auf
zügig entsprechende gesetzliche Regelung
zu vollziehen und hat eine
vortriebsregelung getroffen ihr eigener
Ministerpräsident tut das und deshalb
stelle ich abschließend die Frage
entweder ist das was sie hier vorführen
ein riesiges Schauspiel oder wenn sie es
so ernst meinen haben sie einen
fundamentalen Lizenz einen Bruch in der
Migrationspolitik innerhalb der CDU
klären Sie das bitte und belästigen Sie
nicht uns damit herzlichen Dank
war das für die SPD-Fraktion ja es wird
dieser Gesetzentwurf hier von Nancy
fazer dann doch eben in den Ausschüssen
intensiv diskutiert werden dann geht
dann nach dieser Debatte ins
parlamentarische fahren ja ich darf mich
von heute von hier von ihnen
verabschieden verehrte Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer darf sie auch kurz auf
morgen Hinweisen dann gibt es eine
Regierungserklärung von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz zum Europäischen Rat dann
sind wir ab 8:45 Uhr wieder hier live
für Sie aus dem Deutschen Bundestag
berichten bleiben sie aber auch jetzt
weiter bei Phoenix ist folgt Phoenix der
Tag aus Bonn
Deutschlands liegt
immer am Start Tag und Nacht
twenty four seven
auf Knopfdruck weltweit
stets zu Diensten
für jeden Geschmack